this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
open skies in the Maasai Mara you can
see there's a few little puffy clouds in
the distance but otherwise still a bit
of blue around and fairly warm today
actually it's been quite hot during the
course of the morning which probably
means we gain to get a bit of rain at
some point in fact when I look over the
escarpment they look lots of cloud that
is coming
that's way but my name is Justin on
camera I've got to money this afternoon
and it is a very warm welcome to the
show that comes brings you animals live
in your living room which means that we
want to actually talk to all of you
because otherwise is very boring if we
just drive around and none of you
actually talk to us we like to hear
about all the things that you have to
say but seeking if you have questions
and so if you have questions
hashtag safari live on twitter or @fc on
the YouTube chat and you just have to
keep it relevant to what you're actually
seeing on the screen and we'll hopefully
answer as many as possible you can see
mine is showing you where the clouds are
and maybe a little bit of rain that may
be starting to fall and also where we
are heading so manu and i are going to
be heading in that direction we're going
to be going on to the other side of that
forest in the hopes that we can find all
a lot of pride we had them this morning
they were looking hungry there was
buffalo nearby there was zebras nearby
there was water back giraffe and so
hopefully this afternoon we might get
them up and moving particularly if a
storm starts to roll in there's the dark
cloud that I was telling you coming over
the escarpment and so if that starts to
come in and rain starts to fall I
wouldn't be surprised if the Ola la la
pride decides to start coming moving and
hunting but I'm not the only one out
here this afternoon there will be two of
my co-workers that will be with me one
of them will be down south in South
Africa and his name is Sydney and he
wants to say hello to all of you
so you can see that there is a movement
of a very big animal behind the green
bush is there that is our largest land
mammal is the elephant and a very very
good afternoon and welcome to the
beginning of the afternoon Safari
I am Sydney a former enemy cozy and I'm
traveling with a Craig who is my
professional camera operator we are
going to be with you this afternoon and
we will try by all means and get you see
a lot of interesting animals we are
easily accessible you can follow us for
your questions and comments on Twitter
hashtag Safari live so it's quite a
small head you can see we've got also
the big one and the little one is also
feeding on some of the small trees there
this elephants they are very lucky
because it rained a lot here by the Juma
Game Reserve and the Bush is bringing
all the nutrients they must be enjoying
the taste at the moment elephants don't
worry too much about the taming levels
by this kind of vegetation a tenon is a
poison the trees are secreting in order
to regulate the browsing activities
browsing has got something to do with
the consumption of the leaves from the
trees I am also enjoying the vegetation
when it's looking very green like this
the only challenge by this time of the
year is some of the trees flowering
plants when they are bringing flowers
you pick up different kind of sense some
of the flowers smell sweets and some of
them they smell bad but there is reasons
behind those kind of smells some these
mercies to attract the insects whereas
some they smell bad in order to chase
away the animals who might come and feed
on the flowers
a James the elephants each head of them
which is consisted of the daughters and
the little ones is led by the oldest
material material is the one responsible
is the one in charge of giving orders by
the head so the elephants
without the matriarch is always a
challenge but if they lose the matriarch
another one has to take over and lead
the group unfortunately here the male's
they are not responsible at all and they
don't have any say when it comes to the
decision-making no disagreement between
male and females Vicki the Elie's are
very beautiful animals you can see that
one is feeding on a plant that plant
that can recognize it from far that is
the sickle Bush the signal Bush is one
of the plants which has got a very it's
very rich in terms of the protein
content it contains over 4% of the
proteins so normally you will get the
amount of proteins up to 8% so that's
why this big animals rely on the acacia
trees as well as the signal bushes to
get quite a lot of energy to move that
very big body size Alex the elephants
they don't really have a favorite
specific food but they do have a
specific favorite fruit which is the
Amarula the marula fruit the one which
makes the amar lobia that is there a
special kind of a fruit but when it
comes to the vegetation elephants are
not selective they are Park feeders that
is why these kind of animals don't lose
weight even during the dry season
because they don't have that diet its
consisted of variety of vegetation types
including the grass
so I can see that this elephants they
are moving away and while they are
moving away
let me also lead you to Tristan who is
also moving around the Kenya Masai Mara
I am indeed
on the move like elephants I hope I
don't look like an elephant in the way
that's we get paid to buy a chef Joel in
the Mara it's probably very possible at
this stage of the game we're kind of
moving along you'll see we kind of just
on the edge of the forest at the moment
it's just kind of coming the side and
what's really nice is that we had a
brief view of the Kitchel mail that the
dark of main one and he's on the other
side so everybody has gone that side to
go if you look at him which means that
this side is going to be nice and quiet
and nobody really should be anywhere
near us now money do you think you can
get a bird of prey oh no it's quite far
but let's have a little look-see because
we're still looking out for our snake
eagle which actually I have a nice
update about so one very fortunate thing
about what we do here is that we get to
work with a lot of very very
knowledgeable people the other really
nice side of it is that we get to have a
whole bunch of very knowledgeable
viewers that watch I'll show daily and a
lot of you will contribute a lot there's
a lot of different names that come to
mind so you know Julie H and James
Richard and one other image gentleman
also that helps us a lot is project
alpha now project alpha this morning we
were talking about the snake eagle that
I was saying is very uncommon and he was
saying he has a feeling that we've seen
it before on Drive it was identified at
the time as a black chested snake eagle
at a young black chested snake eagle in
its second per image and but he didn't
really think much it did if they
resembled that and so he kind of sent me
the photos and said what I think and I
forwarded it on to the Raptor guys here
in the Mara and
ask them what their opinion was and they
reckon that he's spot-on in fact it was
that very special snake eagle which I
still can't pronounce by the way and I
actually think we might have found the
other one that's spending time here you
know that this looks just like it
so it has supposed to have a little
white throat patch which this one
actually does look like it would be a
coincidence if we did find it so project
officers well flattery will take us far
thank you hope so now I'm joking it's
just that
Roger golf always helps us with some
very very interesting stuff he often
sins through some really epic articles
of arts studies that are being done in
some very sort of scientific and
technical stuff which is really hugely
valuable and I and that goes to every
single one of you that help us out with
all the things with IDs and everything
like that I don't think you guys a lot
of you realize how appreciate it it
often is by a lot of the presenters yes
I certainly appreciate its I don't know
a lot of the others do when we speak see
a lot of the guys you know everyone kind
of really appreciates being helped out
from time to time as much as we try and
kind of gain knowledge and assimilate
knowledge on our own it's it's just
having a community and having so many
different resources from everybody means
that we all learn that much faster and
that's what makes what we do so especial
and in many respects is that there's
nowhere else where you can have this
many people all together twice a day for
six hours discussing wildlife related
things and actually learn about it so
it's a pretty special
a pretty special thing right now when
it's just double check this bird because
this bird looks very very very hot much
like what we are really looking for and
it's this is the area that it keeps
being seen in so it is a snake eagle you
can see it's got featherless legs right
now its back is almost impossible to
tell but there you can see the barred
tail that is very much a indicative sign
of the species and it does have the
white throats now project alpha what do
you reckon anybody else want to see you
maybe get a screen shot that can make
and blow up if we can just get the bird
to turn again and see what we think I
have a funny feeling that it might be
one of them
apparently there's two or three of them
that comes to the Mara into the Mara
triangle every year it's a very special
bird like I said it's occurs in West
Africa so it's I'll try and said again
bird Danes Algodones with Danis how
would we say it I don't even know how to
say it's I'm butchering the name
horribly French people are gonna kill me
but anyway it's the family that's the
name of it so I'll show you all now so
you can all have a little look at what
how the spelling is but it's very tricky
with snake Eagles archer because you get
the juveniles black chest it's can often
look a little bit like it and so it's
not easy to always tell but this one
definitely has like a creamy what the
throat patch and a Grecia which you know
there's the right kind of things for it
the head just doesn't look quite right
it's so far away that it's tricky to
tell
can you guys also see the spiderweb
that's blowing in the wind - which is
quite cool so project offer your sarakin
it's worth watching if it just turned it
would be so much easier now you can see
there's a bit of the spider webs that
are kind of coming all over the place
now those will just be lines that
despite it throws out and uses to be
able to go to the next place so when it
wants to build a web from one place to
another or one wants to get a long
distance they'll basically do what's
called ballooning so they'll let art
suck and then they use that to be able
to get to another point all basically
the suck to get to another point to then
anchor and be able to then start
building their nests across and
sometimes you get very long strands that
will flutter in the breeze and you can
see how long that one is it's coming all
the way it looks like possibly from an
even past that left-hand tree this bird
I'm not sure I hesitate to make a call
on it
to be honest I'm hoping it will turn it
looks very much like it right well we're
just going to spend a little bit of time
here to see if it will turn or fly for
me and see if we can get anything
diagnostic from there while I do that
though David wants to say good afternoon
and he's with elephants just like Sydney
was hello everyone and it's a bit tricky
sometimes when you see the egos when
they're juveniles that's always a stage
when they could be a bit confusing but
I'm sure Tristan is very good in batting
he is going to figure it out and know
what exactly type of a snake he goatees
well my name is David and good afternoon
everyone and with me on chemistry is
Archie it's a very warm welcome to a
drive I'm on the other side of the Mara
all Tristan is on the other side well
very nice to start with elephants on
such a lovely day in terms of whether
the light is just perfect but a single
drop of rain the elephant's just walking
there and is a small family with the
young ones and remember our safari drive
is always very interactive so your
questions and comments give us lots of
happiness
I'm sure you know how to send them but
I'm very good you the first one to ask
the question and I was just saying on
how to ask questions I'm sure you all
know on Twitter hashtag safari live or
you can keep following us in the YouTube
chat stream
well Bremen I'll tell you the African
elephants to me have slightly larger
years than engineers other than Asian
elephants I guess to consider what
Archie is showing you and in every putt
or in every video gun I would say or
body part of an African elephant it's
big by any standard talk of the ears the
tasks you know the legs the trunks the
tails I personally think that the
African elephant is bigger by maybe
10-15 percent I'd be happy to hear what
Tristan and Sydney would say but ideally
I would say the big and brave I'm still
looking at that ear I remember when we
went college we used to make jokes that
to tell them apart apart from the
obvious differences as you see that one
doesn't have a tail and that's not going
to be one of the differences between
African and Asian elephant while in
college we used to make jokes that to
tell them apart males of the Asian
elephants have tasks and the females you
do not have and the African elephants
it's both sexes in the males and the
females but above all coming back to
your question Bravin if you look at that
eeeyah there we used to say the e of an
elephant or the African elephants looks
or the tick's the shape of an African
map and the ears of Asian elephants look
like the Asian Maps I do not know
whether that makes sense but that's what
we used to say while we went college and
those temperatures are warming up what
this Ely's will keep doing is to keep
flapping their ears I'm sure we all know
the cooling of the blood is done around
the ears so that young calf there who
you will guess could be going to about a
few years of age because grants if it's
young or the small tasks
coming out she just approached the whole
plant for herself so anytime they try to
bring something out of the ground
using the trunks and it doesn't work out
they'll always give it a small node or a
small knock using their feet and that
one helps to bring it out now they got
all the ears out I was saying earlier
just to help cooling off cynic good
question and always very happy to hear
your names Enoch what the people around
here have respect the elephant's very
much
and unless Enoch is a drought and we see
the elephant's getting outside the game
reserve and going out and terrorizing
the locals I'm talking of the elephant's
going to their homes the homes per se
going to their gardens and attacking or
eating their crops Enoch ideally they
have a very good relationship between
elephants and locusts the biggest
challenges in akhira is between the
hippos and the local community and
sometimes the buffalos we have what's
called human world live conflict but we
have lots of game Rangers will always
come around and educate the locals on
what to do and not what to do should
they spot for example elephants from a
distance and they think they're going
the direction towards their villages or
their homes they have what's called
community audience who they report to
and the game rangers will come and push
them back to the game reserve
lovely my plans today I don't want to
look for liens I want to look for the
black rhino but Archie spotted a very
useless bud and I'm sure as Christian is
working on his bud at one point and
she'll come back to me to show you one
very special bud that Archie just
spotted by the meantime let's go fast
back to Tristan well our bird
unfortunately is not helping things at
all at the moment it's really not kind
of playing the game is stay exactly the
way it is but what I can tell you is
that it definitely has a very yellow eye
and a black beak which is the right kind
of diagnostic features for that kind of
bird but so does the black chested but
it just doesn't look right to me for a
black chested youngster it's so tricky
in it this in this particular part of
the world it was so the short ideal also
looks quite similar so I don't know I
mean could it be I was hoping it was
gonna fly off it ruffled its feathers a
little bit just now I was hoping that I
was gonna see it actually take off and
then we could actually get a better sort
of look at it but it really is tricky to
kind of see a lot of definition it's
also against the light which is not
helping at all but you can see though
below it is a giraffe head so far we
kind of hoping that the bird will move
we can discuss your office a little bit
you can also see there's a lot of heat a
so I was saying that it's fairly warm in
the Sun today and it's probably the
warmest day we've had in the last
weekend and that will make things
probably a lot drier which is good for
us but their problem with heaters it
often brings about a lot more sort of
torrential downpours in terms of rain
and so you know I'm hoping that we don't
get rained on this afternoon except that
I do want the auto rollers to start
moving Oh tricky
Kathy exactly so you'll often see bark
spiders they used ballooning quite
regularly when they build their webs
across roads so they'll often use
ballooning to do that and and that will
attach the into the other one from one
side of the road to the other and that
will allow them to then kind of develop
that we've been be able to spin it and
you'll often come across it at night and
should be a good time of year for bark
spiders now that we've had a bit of rain
the guys should start seeing them early
early in the morning you'll often come
across they're more just as it's the Sun
or just after the Sun is set you'll find
them and it's amazing how fast know his
bark spiders are able to spin their webs
all right well we'll leave our Eagle
vets unfortunately not decided to fly
I'm gonna keep an eye out where the
Lions are not far so hopefully it flies
towards us at some point maybe some of
you got some screen shots and and maybe
we can figure it out I don't know let's
let's try and see what we can do this
unfortunately no road that goes any
closer so we have it hamstrung in that
regard but it sounds like David is also
doing a spot of birding and he's found
something delightful to show you
well from one maybe rupture to another
after but I'm sure at one point we are
going to establish quit but the t's and
screenshots will is will make us maybe
sit tonight during dinner and we're
gonna call parents and find out who she
is but we have one here that is illegal
that's in black and white you do not
mystic the secretary bad for any other
bad she's very unique in every shape and
form how she is design her body
morphology basically she is very
different from all the other birds well
I call her the ground eagle as much as
she is now on top of a tortured tree and
she's one of the most beautiful parts of
that size that I would say I don't know
what Archie thinks whether it could be a
favorite for him but he goes of these
highs this is my favorite one and they
tend to spend most of their time on the
ground but we are know
now more convinced than ever before that
they got a nest there Sharon how are you
today
and you saying you adore secretary bud I
agree with you a hundred percent it
could not be anything better
Sharon think of his bad when she walks
on the ground I'm sure you've seen how
the ground there very majestic when they
walk and the feathers how they stick out
behind their heads and he said that tail
feather there it is very unique it
doesn't remind me the peacock because
when she got her wings out she doesn't
look like a peacock but that tail went
if you know the tail feathers when they
are out they make her very very
good-looking well she's an eagle as I
said earlier and she spends most of the
time feeding on the ground and we call
her the secretary bird which i think is
Arabic French corruption of Arabic
secretary which means a hunt as bad so
many birds will eat snakes just like
exactly horde twisting hard but this
one's to be experts in eating snakes not
experts as snakes being the main diet
but is how they kill them you see them
tramping
snakes you know they have a skill on how
they bring down snakes they walk very
majestic in the grass and the moment
they spot one you see them live just
like that like a servo catch step on it
and using the other foot in
ding-ding-ding-ding and they kill it and
interestingly more from than not they'll
always swallow this snakes life well
there are two on that tree let me see if
we could be lucky to see the other one
and as I found out whether there could
be two all the visuals to be good will
take you back to South Africa to Sydney
who got some very huge vamos
so the ælis are now starting to come out
of the clear space you can see that they
are not deep in the thick bushes anymore
but say they are still concentrating on
some of the a thorny trees now they are
feeding on one of the Virginia which is
the acacia this is the biggest I have
seen so far and not very far away this
even a little one this one might be the
female which is nursing their little
ones if you look at the trunk when is
trying to pick up some leaves you will
see that this trunk does not have the
knobs sometimes elephants you will see
the trunk having some kind of knobs on
it when is having the knobs it is a sign
of a milk deficiency normally you will
see those kind of knobs by the small
ones if the mother dies when having a
lactating small one if that small one is
not gonna get a lot of milk you will see
the milk deficiency in the sign of the
symptoms will be the knobs on the trunk
so about elephants they are so very
social in such a way that the other
lactating females can also nest the
little one when the mother is dead
so the little ones they are going to be
Lisa
the elephants they eat quite a lot the
elephants eat approximately 400
kilograms a day and from the 400
kilograms they eat there only just to go
they are only just going to digest for
the eight percent and forty eight
percent is a too little that is why the
insects my favorite insects such as dung
beetles they prey on elephant dung
because there is quite a lot of whole
nutrients available in their droppings
so there's droppings looks very much
green and if you open them not finally
digested and reach in terms of water
so if we check there you will see that
King say that is true
it is quite a lot so it's a sign to us
that elephants and needs quite a lot of
vegetation to survive so it is punishing
the elephants having the elephants in
the area which is not having a lot of a
lot of trees and a lot of grass for them
to eat so and they drink 150 to 200
liters a day so it's not only about the
trees they must also have to be quite a
lot of water availability so that they
can be able to digest the trees nicely
some people will tell you elephant is
got a poor digestive system and I don't
think they've got a poor digestive
system that is how they digest that
they've got to defecate after every 45
minutes so every 45 minutes you will see
the droppings coming out so that is
clear that they do digest the food and
this food has to come out after a very
short period so you can see now it's
time to eat the grass child of the
universe fortunately the thorns by the
trees don't really affect the elephants
and the inner parts of the elephant
mouth is adapted to eat this kind of
thorn trees ferns are nothing compared
to the spines elephants eat the sickle
boss sickle Bush is a spine tree a spine
is that modified stem which has got some
of the leaves growing on them and it's
very hard sometimes you can even punch
your tyres by driving over the elephant
dance that is how strong the spine is
so it's not ideal at all to drive over
the elephant dance but apart from
running away from the thorns and spines
by this time of the year after their
heavy rainy season the dung beetles are
back and some of the dung beetles they
feed from underneath dead stop droppings
and as I have indicated earlier they
prefer the elephant dung and because of
that they stay underneath the elephant
dung droppings so you must have to avoid
driving over the elephant dance by all
means otherwise you are going to kill
the significant insects such as dung
beetles who are here in order to
facilitate a lot of decomposition in the
bush
so you can see that a very big animal
can easily hide behind this bushes so
now let's cross over to the Maasai Mara
where David is waiting also to take over
well very good sitting and talking of
dung beetles I have always noticed dang
beaters prefer more buffalo poo to make
the balls of dung balls than maybe
elephant a the elephant dung I don't
know what silly you might think we have
gotten yourself a small herd of
buffaloes here and the taking advantage
of the grass now having all the
migration or all the wildebeest gone
back to Serengeti National Park in
Tanzania this is the African Buffalo its
heart of males and females together
you
so you can see that these elephants are
slowly moving much more towards our side
I can see that some of these head
members are slowly making their way in
it's just that they are being kept busy
by these trees they are getting excited
with the nutritious trees so I'm just
gonna try and pull forward a little bit
as the big one is now approaching a nice
and very clear space so we're going to
have a good sighting from there
here they are nice and close so you can
see that they are just coming from the
mudbath a child of the universe the
trees is just that a lot of people they
give a different temps when it comes to
the chemicals produced by these trees
some will tell you the trees they
release a tree fennel in order to
regulate browsing some will tell you
they produce something called a prompt
aconitine and some will tell you the
tree produce attaining all these things
they serve same purpose which is a
regulation of the browsing activities on
this face
so you can see that now these elephants
are feeding on the grass is not only
specifically feeding on trees so it's a
confirmation of effect that elephant our
Baraka feeders they are not even taking
the grass is completely from the ground
sometimes when the shortage of food
availability you will see them taking
the whole plant and shake it in order to
get rid of the sand before they take the
grass toodle to the mouth but now they
are just taking the top part every time
taking the top part which is something
good so this shows that elephants they
do play a significant role when it comes
to the stimulation of the growth by the
grasses
so now let's across over to the Maasai
Mara
where the Buffaloes are also having some
grasses at the moment difference between
buffaloes and elephants when it comes to
feeding the elephants will variously
diversify and in terms of drought we
have always seen should say the two
species die because of starvation
elephants may die last elephants are
able to diversify from the grass they'll
go to the leaves from the leaves will go
to twigs from tweaks and they'll go to
three bucks and when you know a
situation becomes very bad yeah I also
able to dig food for himself on the
ground which the Buffaloes will not be
able to do now look on the horizon there
and that is the eastern side of the Mara
triangle and what we're seeing are very
thick and heavy clouds an indication
that it might be a bit too much later
but from where we are so far so good as
Tristan was saying earlier we are on the
onset of the short rains in Kenya LT in
East Africa in general and the Mara
triangle is not exceptional
so every other day I would say we have
had about 40 60 millimetres of rainfall
that's my guess and there a couple of
days we have had like a whole 36 hours
or frein now that reminds me of June
July in the middle of Asia
we had very heavy rains King that's very
good question in Kenya out say we have
two seasons of rainfall we have the
short Saints and the long rains and
apart from that normally we normally
have out say summer all around a long
rains are over and they ended around
June July what we have now are the short
rains but I'll say they were the parts
in the last few years in Africa have
been quite erratic what I would call
short rains might turn out to be very
big rains I mean yesterday I was out in
the drive in the afternoon and I got
stuck for
minutes not because of the rain of
yesterday but just because of the mud
the kind of geology here we have water
called a black cotton soil and when it
rains it becomes very sticky so me and
Kristin when we drive we have to be very
careful well I'm not going to wait for
the rains to come and I'm not sure
whether this top he is aware that rains
are coming what it want us to go or we
would want Tristan to show us some lions
before maybe the storms arrive yes we
have found exactly hoping for and look
at that she's going to walk right past
us as she came to walk within the few
meters which is my favorite thing when
Lions do this she should be walking
probably I would say within about a
metre of where we are which you can see
that she is looking at them so food is
going to be high up on the list of
priorities for that lioness and I wonder
if now with the rain and the wind just
starting that this is going to be the
start of them starting to wake up and
moving and trying to go the problem is
the rest of them are all fast asleep as
you can see that's one of the young boys
that's taking a nap at the moment
hopefully he is going to be able to wake
up soon and will be able to see what
whether or not they are actually going
to wake up properly and decide to move
but you can see very fast asleep now
he's got a slightly full of there I'm
sure that stole from the Buffalo that
they had a few days ago they finished
that Buffalo two days ago so I as far as
we know they haven't eaten since then
unless they ate something very small
which is possible they could have eaten
something like an Impala or maybe
something like a warthog of small
warthog so they haven't had a big meal
though as far as we know yeah and that
means that these guys will win all
likelihood given the size of the pride
we'll want to probably try and find some
semblance of food I'm just going to see
where she's going at the moment so she's
on the road walking but before we get
into that right I had a quick sort of
thing just hold on Manu sorry and let me
just try to sort this out because I've
got the wrong thing on here now give me
two seconds okay
yeah all right so this is that Eagle
what it's supposed to look like in
flight right so this is what the the the
image when I search images that's in
flight now we managed to while we were
kind of doing things managed to get one
in flight so that's a shot that I got of
this bird in flight the one we just saw
taking off and to me they look very very
very similar and so I think it is
actually very special eagles so that
should be a lifer for many of you now
I'll make 100% sure and send it off just
to double-check but I think that we
managed to find the bird that we were
looking for which is how cool is that
considering we were talking about it it
doesn't happen like that very often and
it's happened to me twice this week last
week I mean nearly on the week I said it
would be a nice place to find the Rufus
bellied Heron and we caught a reef is
buried here and then we talked about the
sneaking we've got that too but the
lioness is walking so enough about our
snake eagle which I'm excited about so
it's nice when you get to see a lifer as
a guide you don't get to see them all
the time and especially them you know
when you get to spend a lot of time in
the bush life has become fewer and fewer
and fewer and harder and harder to come
by so
so projects alpha says you're convinced
that's the one thank you exclamation
points absolute pleasure
very very cool that we can actually
confirm and we can have that I would
like to know from some of you
particularly those that have kept
extensive Maher Ellis what number it is
for you guys I know a lot of you do keep
worthless and so it's nice that you do I
find it very cool that you do it's a
special thing that you can say that
you've seen this many birds on cameras
in in Africa which live which is very
cool so I would like to know from
apologies for the inconvenience is on
behalf of the team
the signals are bad at the moment by the
masai mara but will it will come back
soon now I am heading much more towards
the buffers hook them just to go and see
if we cannot find any of the spotted cat
in the area my specific target is over
sana I have seen what yesterday I'm just
going to check it from previous it just
went towards the touchwood and he was
doing some hunting maybe we might be
lucky around the buffer sukhiya Marion
so he was coming from this area
yesterday afternoon and we escorted him
all the way down from the buffers them
to the fire break so I have not yet
picked up the tracks of any of these
spotted cats at the moment neither the
Alliance nor the lab as yet
so now let's quickly go back to the
Maasai Mara and carry on from previous
my apologies again they is a challenge
to do with the network this afternoon so
let's see what we are going to find here
by the powerful hook them so you can
hear the woodland Kingfisher is giving
us a warm welcome to the dam so that was
quite a lovely call from the woodland
Kingfisher Oh more elephants here where
we are at the moment and this elephant
has got some small babies
so the elephants are moving much more
towards this side way we I will see
they've got some small babies there look
at that tiny little baby is underneath
the mom is crossing just underneath you
can see it's so small can be able to
pass in between the legs between the
front and the hind legs so maybe it's
time now for the little one to have
something to drink
so elephant is the only it's one of
those animals which can get up girl and
the elephants they don't choose the
trees but some of the trees elephants
Anna's never saw them eating trees such
as the euphorbia trees the euphorbia
trees are those kind of species of trees
which has got a very high milk
production so when the tree is secreting
quite a lot of Latics latex is that milk
coming from the leaves elephants they do
avoid those kind of trees and apart from
that elephant don't like the chillies
they don't like the pepper chilies
because of what is called a capsize in
molecule a molecule which gives a chilli
a hot sensation elephants can be able to
pick it up from a distance and avoid
those kind of trees and sometimes they
even avoid those kind of areas
so you can see that this elephants they
look wet a little bit which is a sign
that they have been to the water or
maybe the mud is from here where we have
just arrived the buffalo parts work them
if not from here it means is from oh
look at that tiny little one day so if
it's not from here it means it's from
one of the water holes they have created
elephants they are very good when it
comes to the creation of the natural
water holes look at that little one day
so elephants are very peaceful animals
but when the little ones are still small
and when they've got injuries when the
bullies or must is when they can be very
much dangerous
so that little one is very much small
but the little one at the moment is
relying on the mother for feeding
purposes until they get to three years
is when they are going to start feeding
by themselves but from the head to
remain with the other ones we've got to
leave until the sixteen years after
sixteen years is then that their little
ones are going to become independent so
is normally when it comes to us humans
18 years is when we are starting to
become independent so the elephants
they're just doing it's two years before
that
MW Chili's is something which can but
Chile's is also very much important
where I come from inventor we sternum
believe that eating quite a lot of
Chili's will fight against flu it will
also help you against the flu so in
other words you can use chilies for
medicinal papers
so these armors the elephants are one of
those species which can be able to
regurgitate water if you look at the
elephant here if you look at the
elephant here on the mouth path the
lower jaw they after the lower jaw
they've got a space like this this is
Ferengi approach sporangia Porsche is
what is used in order to collect water
and when hearing the elephants making
that sound of this Ferengi approach is
the ones which amplifies that sound that
sound is not directly coming from the
stomach it is coming from
and Tristan is already lucky with one of
the cats
he's got the Lions at the moment and
let's go see them by the Maasai Mara
indeed I am lucky Sydney because we have
the most epic backdrop with our pride of
lions we've managed to find a few more
of them that were kind of in this areas
the female was walking and so we thought
we'd come to the side and we can
actually see a whole lot that it just
popped their heads up in front of us and
even know half of them were there but in
front next to that mound as you can see
is all bunch of them that we didn't had
no idea they even around so one two
three four five six of them and are
sitting over there at least they might
even be more so that's a lot of the
sub-adults doesn't look like any adult
females within that group I don't think
and they're all just kind of having a
bit of a look but the storm is blowing
in and you can see the Lions are a lot
more away awake than when we first got
you now if you look at this storm what's
going to happen is this should sweep in
kind of and come along this escarpment
it often does so it often comes along
the escarpment here and it starts to
then kind of rain along here and if it
does that well then the conditions are
right for lions because one is this
going to be wouldn't which is going to
make it very difficult for things like
zebra or water back or giraffe which are
all around this area warthogs to hear
anything the other thing is that you're
going to get a rain which makes it very
difficult to see and so the Lions then
utilize that to the advantage it also
gets a lot darker and so they blend in a
little bit better and that could be the
perfect kind of thing for them I'm just
sad and in some respects is that that
buffalo herd is not still milling around
I'm sure it's the same heard that David
has gotten they must have gone back down
towards the marsh area and it's a bit of
a shame because in these conditions
Lions I think these lions would have had
a crack at those Buffalo it would have
been a really interesting kind of
development and watching how they would
have gone about it given that there's a
lot of sub-adults yeah I would have been
intrigued to watch them try and hunt
Buffalo because I think it would have
been a tough assignment for them but
isn't that beautiful
the light is seriously amazing there's
also a little bit of a rainbow that's
just starting to develop now so
hopefully what we going to get is we're
going to get the typical kind of line in
the open
and the big tree and then the storm in
the background with a bit of a rainbow
forming wouldn't that be quite a
spectacular kind of image I hope that's
what happens because I think it's
absolutely beautiful that kind of image
right there for me is always an image of
East Africa and its kind of lure that it
often has had but you can see it a
little male that's kind of walking off
now but what you'll notice with him too
is also in need of food again it's
amazing how fast they digest you
wouldn't expect these guys to kill to
Buffalo this week and still be in the
shape that they're in it you would have
thought the native had nice big round
tummies but just goes to show how
quickly these guys can digest Buffalo
when they have fed on that so hopefully
it's afternoon and I'll gamble to come
here this afternoon will pay off so
child over the universe it is a big
pride at 16 in total without the
coalition males that are ones that
produced these Cubs and it's the oral
law or n gamma pride we used to call it
the n gamma pilot that's the most of the
guide see I call it the OL role of all
long normal pride which is the name of
the Cisco plant that's in the background
so it provides the perfect backdrop for
where they are and what you'll probably
find is I have a funny feeling that
these guys are not going to hunt their
way into the reserve I think they're
gonna hand their way up the escarpment
which obviously means we're not going to
follow them too far but let's see how we
heart plays out I'm just gonna catch up
with those guys there for you
wonderfully you're not right on the
longest end of your lens hopefully the
rest of them will slowly start to kind
of come through the rainbows developing
nicely which is great news so we should
really nice rainbow and lion sort of
storm me nice all right guys one of you
needs to sits on top of the mountain
Arthur and I can get you out of the
grass we'll be in treatment and where we
going to line it up so that we can get
this right
so I don't know how long our rainbow is
going to last so to try now while we've
got it's visible and if you guys can
actually see it it's very faint in the
background there so kind of going over
the left-hand line it's is where that
rainbow will roughly be there it is this
so money is trying to kind of get it
it's not bright bright bright but
hopefully it will brighten up and
strengthen a little bit and then don't
you think it will be absolutely
beautiful to have rainbow lines in the
long grass and that storm just kind of
going across the plains I think it'll be
a wonderful kind of way to spend our
afternoon I thoroughly am looking
forward to watching them go about their
business exactly that will do but you
can see they're definitely a lot more
alert than what we had when we finished
driving this morning it's exactly what
we thought the view they would do so
it's kind of raced up and now when the
weather starts to turn with the heat
that we had today it was bound to happen
and start to now come into you know
their own and start to think about
finding and looking for any sort of
sustenance the fake in it
so Cathy in in Juma you see them going
for shelter very quickly and there's
water back right up on the ridge that
they probably are watching at the moment
so in Juma you'll find they'll get under
the concern they'll just kind of curl up
in there here in the Mara sometimes the
nearest tree is quite far away and so
sometimes they just tough it out they
just sit then they get pelted or they'll
try and get to the nearest big tree in
which case they'll kind of get under and
they'll just lie there and I mean they
still get wait there's really very
little in the way of cover for a lot of
the the cats Archer they unfortunately
unless they're very close to forested
section they're going to just get wet
and the problem with being in the
forested areas is that those are very
prone to flash flooding effect and so
it's actually not the great place for
them to be either so they just have to
be toughened and take it and they so
used to it these lines I mean they've
been getting hit by rain for most of
their lives now you'll see the last two
that we left all the way back down there
where we first started they on their way
so that's the young male and the little
young female and they're kind of moving
up towards us as well at the moment
which is good so the whole pod should
come together now if you want to know
where the kind of kitc were male is he's
pretty much directly across from where
we are now so on just on the other side
of the forest so if you look at those
guys just on the other side of the
forest area that's where the Kitchener
male is at the moment we saw a whole
bunch of Kazi and I could see him
through my binaries when we drove fast
but I wanted to come to the side just to
make sure these guys hadn't gone they as
well and now sorry I mean if you can
just repeat the name for me the wind is
howling and I've got the escarpment and
animals living there but I didn't get
the name so if you can repeat that
deadly spunky that is that is quite the
Twitter handle or handle whichever one
it is on YouTube or - it's a bit deadly
spunky do any other do any animals live
on the escarpment
so primarily on the escarpment not too
many you you'll find Elance read-back
like it's up there quite a bit they
spend a lot of time they although they
do come down and the lions were up there
lots lip it up there are lots and Sara's
up and down elephants at nights love the
escarpment but then come down during the
day see what else do we see going up and
down in parlors up and down a lot of
baboons they love it here so this is a
great place will be Boone's they've both
thickets where they can roost then along
the escarpment stew feed during the day
and I'm pretty sure you'll find very
small animals I'm pretty sure there's
certain mouse species that will probably
exclusively live just up in the rocky
sections on the escarpment itself lots
of different types of birds that you see
up there so or down into these forested
sections there we go you see we just
have to talk and they will listen
eventually named Puma duck duck exactly
they'll be up there and these two that
live very close to our camp funny enough
and you can see them most days if you
look out for them so they're up and
they're not gonna say a few reptiles few
different types of birds is actually a
really beautiful snake that occurs up
here that is called a Jameson's Mamba
and so we get a black mamba and there's
one called a Jamison which is a
beautiful greenish colored snake very
very pretty and they occur in these
forested sections up on the escarpment
as well so it's a great place to
actually find them and it's obviously
very dangerous but a very pretty snake
what else is up in these areas they have
been reports in the in this sort of
forested sections of the escarpment of
giant forest hog but I mean I don't know
I think that's a bit of a push a little
bit now it's right what is that one you
want to get a two-shot sure
let me get manu in sacred place the
money I like working with Manu because
one is really creative when we are sure
he likes to get really epic imagery and
is constantly looking for nice ways to
kind of show off all the animals that we
see on a regular basis and new kind of
techniques and and often comes up with
some very very cool concepts oh so it's
cool to work with money because he often
likes to do things differently and he
will ask and try and point things out
which really helps to be able to get
visuals like that where we can watch the
uncoming members moving towards the rest
of the pride isn't that cool so you can
see them kind of striding towards the
one up on the mound so well done Manu
very good eyes they're good to the
thinking but I'm glad they went up the
mound they listened to us so he said to
them they need to go up and sit on top
there because we want the storm in the
background and we want them and now the
others approaching has just made it even
that much better
very very cool shot that yeah but a
Sunday in the background as well
absolutely amazing
how cool is the shut was very cool mono
is a real artist you write like I say is
very good with this kind of stuff every
li enjoy a lot of his footage that I've
seen I mean obviously don't haven't
worked with him as much as I probably
would like to and I I would I would like
to one day see Manu and Archie and James
all come down to South Africa and start
and do some forming of lipids and
various other things but they money
death definitely has a good good way
with the camera and an incredibly fast
with it he's taking a leaf out of Liam
and I mean vehement Brian's book I don't
know why I said him vehement and spoke
with as to to kind of pace with
movements with a camera and it's
obviously some of the cheetah and set
monies for door on Nick's nipples very
very cool when we fortunate I mean all
of our cam ups have their strengths
they've all very good at what they do
and as much as they we give them a lot
of trouble they are a professional Bunch
they generally are the first guys on the
vehicles things always done well and
then they really do strive to to make
sure that they bring you the best images
and I can promise you because we do
reviews and various other things that
they are as hard on each other and
themselves as anybody could imagine and
so you know they really do try give you
guys the best that we can possibly get
given that it's very difficult thing
that they're doing you must remember
that most documentaries that you guys
are watching the cameraman are not
having to worry at all about doing a
live show they are having to just sit on
the side of a car they know generally
the cause of both perfectly for filming
and and they're able to kind of get the
camera as low as possible and they sit
there and they have nobody moving the
car it's just them normally and they
don't have to worry about anything
now our our cameramen have a camera
that's probably not in the most ideal
place for filming of wildlife it's great
for the way we do our safari but
obviously not in a way of filming
wildlife and on top of that they've got
these hooligan guides that move around
and will shake and make these shots
unsteady from time to time and really
just cause havoc so you know they have a
tough time with us and we you know I'm a
very lucky that we do have the guys that
we do so well done to all of our come up
so
don't think they get enough of a pat on
the back at times that's for sure anyway
how cool was that that was very very
cool I knew you did well you can see the
storm is now coming across and we're
gonna get hit soon if you're looking
straight ahead of us it's quite nice
because you can actually see the sort of
edge of the rain there on this sort of
edge of the the hill as it's coming down
you can see how if the hill is slowly
just but surely disappearing as the rain
is coming towards us so we will probably
have to drop cover shortly but in the
meantime that sends you back down to
Sydney and see how he's getting on
so I am now hitting much more to us the
Chitra area I am driving just by the
border between us and the Thai food
which is the area where husana went to
yesterday so I'm trying to check if he's
back at the property or still by the
church roadside but I have not yet
picked up any convincing evidence about
him going in or out I didn't copy the
question clearly if you can repeat that
Emma
Elesha I am live from the western side
of the greater Kruger National Park now
so the show it is an interactive live
Safari as I'm talking now you can talk
to me is happening now
so let's hope to see asana that is also
my hope for this afternoon
and this is the area where I have seen
husana disappearing to the touch wood
and have also met a hyena yesterday
coming towards the same direction
you know the hyenas I am using them for
orientation and navigation of the
spotted cat these days
so now I'm just going to carry on and
make a ten by the chitwa chitwa
waterhole and see if we cannot find any
of the cat or any of the interesting
animals in that area I'll come back
later on here and listen maybe we might
hear Tigana throwing oh we might be
lucky and come across the fresh tracks
of asana the weather is now getting
better is getting cool which is going to
obviously encourage asana to do some
hunting as yesterday we left him hunting
unless you already got a kill at the
moment
and he was so hungry yesterday afternoon
some show maybe already got something
small or something big and it was
something big to us the church would is
going to be difficult for me to see him
for a couple of days
so let's all be caught something on our
side
so there's quite a lot of impalas in the
area where we are at the moment a lot of
impalas in the area and when there's too
much impalas like this it gives me a lot
of confidence that the spotted cats
might be around so we might be lucky as
per your request and see the hyenas I
will also try and visit the den maybe
during the final stage of the game Drive
we do see it as a call six here in Juma
is just that the sightings for those
kind of beautiful cats are very much
rare but we do see them so I just want
to check some tracks here Kraig my
professional camera operator spotted
something I just want to see what is it
that he has just spotted now so he has
just spotted some ally on tracks I just
want to confirm where these tracks are
heading to maybe we can be able to see
these tracks from here
so there is some lion tracks as
somewhere here and we were just gonna
try and go to the nearest water hole
which is the cheetah cheetah maybe we
might be lucky when we get there
otherwise I've got to come back and
carry on by the juma side
and niconico
viewer ad alliance they've got a very
good eyesight both during the daytime
and at night those kind of animals at
night can see very well what helps the
animals which are much more active
during the night to see well is the
following if you look at the Lions not
only the Lions together with the
leopards and other cats sometimes dogs
as well you will see their good whiskers
here those whiskers are called a very
CIO those whiskers are not there just
for decoration they are there to serve a
very significant purpose because they
are connected with the brain they can be
able to pick up what is coming in front
and measure the space in within the
trees as they are walking at night so
those whiskers are connected with the
nervous coordination which then conveyed
which is getting the message from the
brain in order to alert the animal about
the surrounding at night and some beds
as well they do have those kind of
whiskers it's just that they are not
called whiskers by the bed
so we are now slowly approaching the
cheetah cheetah without all you can see
right in the middle of the road we have
got the Egyptian Gil which is saving is
a big sign that we are not far away from
the waterhole
so there is an Egyptian goo now as a a
few of them crossing to the bushes there
they are just about a few kilometer
few meters away from the waterhole maybe
is approximately a kilo
so they are leading us to the Chitra
sheet or towel at the moment where we
are hoping to see something interesting
this afternoon so it's a Gyptian goose
as just a led by all water points
but this is not a cheeto cheeto bottle
with I will show you those kind of areas
way we sing you can see their living is
small and what a point there that what a
point probably has been designed by the
elephant that's why that what a point
does not have a shape because elephants
when they come they don't worry about
the shape of the water point what they
do is to dig the ground and the ground
starts collecting water and they come
from what wallowing Rhino come to the
very same area
what rocks you will see them there and
suddenly this is going to be a very big
natural waterhole
so naturally animals they do try and
create their own water holes it's just
that the water holes which are dug by
the animals don't necessarily meet the
requirements for predation because a
predation needs quite a lot of thick
bushes nearby so that they can be able
to hide when the animals are coming to
drink so when it's done naturally like
this you can see it's much more open it
is this a termite mound here and some of
the trees which can assist some of the
predators to come and with
back everybody sorry that we have a few
gremlins unfortunately the way things
are with storms on the side and a few
issues in juma but we have the most epic
epic scene look at this isn't that
everything that you could have asked for
you've got a rainbow lions at the bottom
of its big tree on the right East Africa
right there spoiling us better than we
could ever ever imagine is that not
sensational I think so I think it's
possibly one of the most kind of epic
sort of scenes I've seen in quite some
time so really really beautiful and we
fortunate that the rainbow is just kind
of somehow lined up exactly with this
line that's on top of this mounds
we've been spoilt in in this regard and
I'm super excited that we managed to
actually get it live because I was a bit
worried at one point I thought maybe
just maybe we were gonna have a bit of
an issue and that we weren't going to
get it right but we've managed somehow
to sort everything out where our tech
geniuses have and we're back with you
know Emma's suggested a very good idea
that's it's probably a good time for a
one word tweet as to what you think of
that image right there I think it's
pretty spectacular so I want to know
from you guys what your one word tweet
is for that yes Emma sometimes you have
moments a billion so now I can you guys
see that there's a second rainbow
forming as well so it's not just one
rainbow is actually two of them that are
forming which is quite something we like
I say are being spoiled by the fact that
we have that kind of shot right there
and it's everything I was hoping it
would be I was really kind of hoping
that we were in agates a really epic sky
and in one of them on the mound that
didn't quite expect to get a beautiful
rainbow as strong as colored as that but
you know we you risk it you gamble it
and that's what you kind of get silent
for me that's absolutely beautiful
and you say wow double rainbow lion
cuddle puddle
I agree isn't it's something and this
noise of the storm as well while it's be
kind of sitting here so far we haven't
got wet pretty sure we're about to gets
absolutely drenched mana and I have
risked it we've decided we're going to
go for the the risk and we're going to
keep the the rain covers off for now I'm
pretty sure we're going to probably not
be very impressed with ourselves just
now when we have to scramble when the
rain really does come down but it seemed
like a worthwhile risk doesn't it I
don't know what do you guys think Dave
oh you say awesomeness yes
well there's not very much else you can
say about something like this is there
it is awesomeness at its very best for
me at least I think it's very very cool
I'm thoroughly thrilled that we managed
to get it for you guys more than
anything else like I said I was giving
up it's kind of stressed because I was
thinking short with the kind of gremlins
and lions on a mound and rainbows that
doesn't really exactly last all that
long and so we're gonna cut it fine in
terms of being able to show you but
somehow someway or pull together and we
ended up with what we wanted which is
perfect so very very very very fortunate
to have gotten that now hopefully we'll
get one more that will kind of go up
onto the land you can see everyone's
kind of looking around and sort of
listening and
aremy you say magical yes you can see
why it's called the magical Mara's and
when you get scenes like that from time
to time it gives you an idea of why it's
kids given that's knave that's for sure
it really is a special place when these
kind of things happen from a scenery
point of view you know Jim has got many
many many amazing things about it from a
scenic point of view though I don't know
if it quite compares to the Mara in
terms of just the visitors that you get
there's this parts of Jummah that are
pretty but not quite as pretty as this
because often and you mean you get very
obscured when it comes to a storm like
this and the rainbows and all that kind
of stuff whereas here you've just got
the such clean view that kind of goes
out that it really is quite spectacular
so very fortunate to be able to kind of
bring these two units it complements
juma so nicely I think in many respects
because of its kind of open nature it's
pretty to rich it's it's predators that
we don't see maybe as much a tumor that
it really allows us to kind of work hand
in hand with that and I like the
combination of the two I think they
provide balance which is nice I mean I
know a lot of you are you've ajumma fans
and not so much Thomas a great job
getting the Lions to cooperate well I
wasn't me it's all thanks to money
making us move it's any reason I saw it
is because actually we were sitting here
and then it just started to kind of
develop and we just slightly positioned
ourselves better and we managed to kind
of get it right so we can actually think
manifold of this he was the one that got
this all kind of into the right space
but for me that was absolutely beautiful
I'm hoping the way the wind is blowing
we might might just squeak out of this
and get lucky and not get ruit's
I somehow don't think it's going to
happen but you never know you might get
lucky yeah it seems to be blowing across
us likely rather than towards us le as
you can see petrified they are nervous
know the lines here also used to thunder
and lightning you can see they're not to
space I think if a crack of lightning
yet to hit right here next to us and and
you know be very close to them yes they
would probably jump and run a little bit
but you must remember like I say for
them this is par for the course almost
daily you get these thunderstorms like
this some way in the Mara so these guys
get quite used to the fact that rain is
part and parcel of their life and and so
you'll find that they're not that fazed
by it you can see off of them are still
sleeping they don't even actually
worried too much about thunder and
lightning and we can hear a lot of
thunder and lightning already coming our
way so are there some giraffe as well
isn't that pretty
some giraffe that are coming from behind
the lines at the moment Roxy they all my
pots of gold now wouldn't it be
something now we're gonna throw this out
there because why not we wouldn't be
living the dream as it is what if these
giraffe walk behind the Lions rainbow
giraffe lions like in a little constant
teen effect I think that'll be pretty
something I think it would be really
really nice that'll be winning I think
exactly something from The Lion King the
problem is is that the rain is going to
start so what I might do is actually
just turn us around so that what I can
do is have the back flaps and one side
down and we could still watch what goes
on because the storm will come in from
the left so if I'm the way that I am I'm
gonna have a bit of a troubles as you
get it right so you just give me
two seconds just to turn around quickie
and then I can drop one side and we're
going to have too much of an issue so I
do apologize
right so while we do that and while we
sort ourselves out I'm gonna send you
quickly across to Sydney and see how
he's doing battling his gremlins
hopefully he's going to get it right I
am still looking for this spot of cars
Here I am now just around the chitwa
chitwa doing and tracking by all means
but still no sign of any of these
leopards in this area so where I am is
the suitable area for checking but I am
not seeing any evidence here showing
that this cat has been here
I'm just trying to investigate one of
the tracks here but I saw it was a check
from one of the dogs
so the only animal I'm seeing at the
moment here is the guinea Falls
let's see the guinea fowls are also
having something to eat here at the
moment so the guinea fires the nest on
the ground but for safety you will see
them high up by the trees so look at
what these guinea fowls are doing that's
why they called their group of
Greenville is called a confusion and see
they're just running everywhere
confusing at the moment with the spots
on the offenders
this helps them in order to confuse
their predators they also do get rotated
sometimes big cats such as the leopard
do predate this kind of pairs so you can
see they can run very fast look at that
so by this time of the year is when the
guinea fires are having the tapeworms we
can eat the guinea fowls we just got to
be very careful because by demand with
letter R is when they've got quite a lot
of tapeworms in the stomach so eating
the guinea fowls by this time of the
year can jeopardize you when it comes to
the tapeworms
mrs. left-wing the givers are so pretty
you can see they are joined by a hammer
cop so the hammer cop is somewhere on
the right side there so they are both
feeding together
so again if ours are some of those beds
which will always give you an alarm call
and then it's very easy to distinguish
their call from the rest of the beds
they don't have same call they have got
different kind of course and when they
are not happy about something they are
going to be vocal and making use of a
very unique call
Frances the guinea fires the ex they are
good to eat because this kind of birds
quite a lot of African tribes they do
eat their eggs so their eggs are not bad
to eat we can eat them so now let's
cross over to the Masai Mara where
Tristan is having one of the tallest
animals
I do indeed I've got the tallest of the
tall that have moved in and they just
watching proceedings with the the lions
at the moment they are not too stressed
though because you can see the Lions
well they haven't even noticed the
giraffe ears I didn't think so it's all
just a case of them having a bit of a
nap everybody is fairly relaxed at the
stage and I don't think in all
likelihood these lions would hunt these
giraffe just given the fact that there's
not really any young giraffe there
though it's all quite large if there was
a small baby then yes
and I think we might see you know the
clients get a little bit more kind of
interested but with just the size of
those two off I think they'll watch them
but I don't think they'll actually have
a real go at them to be honest
isn't it beautiful there you can see the
giraffe have seen the Lions they fully
aware that they are lines around and
that's why they just slowly kind of
walking along making sure that there's
no others that are close by every now
and then gazpacho difficult to know how
many times they hunt a week because it
is variable some weeks they'll hunt a
lot more some weeks a lot less so when
the migration is here sometimes they'll
kill indiscriminately and kill 6 7 8 9
volt of Easter nights for the whole week
other times like now they might have a
lean week where there and you get a
buffalo and that last them for the
entire week so it's difficult to say but
generally what we from kind of
statistically speaking every sort of
three days is what we'll see from these
guys in terms of
actual hunting and I'm in terms of meal
if you have to average it all out three
H days but sometimes more sometimes less
for me you know lines animals at all
hunts whenever the opportunity comes
their way so and a big pride like first
probably hunts more regularly than
others because there's so many miles to
feed that even if they bring down
something like a zebra they're still
gonna have to try they missed to get
more food to be able to sustain
everybody so just depends on kind of the
individual pride and the structures that
you have very special though what we all
witness this afternoon not from a kind
of behavioral point of view but just
from from a aesthetic point of view I
think is the probably the best word for
this up for me it's kind of one of those
very very special sightings in many
respects the light is very very pretty
isn't it now you'll see look at that
isn't that special
very very cool
well I think so like I said you guys
don't have to agree with me but that's
how I think I think it's as good as it
gets and well with us coming here if I'm
honest for me it's worth at least I've
sebastien in certain areas yes giraffe
are high up on the menu and will be
chased by lions regularly just depends
on the area that the Lions live in and
what potential food items they possibly
face and so you know yeah there's a lot
of other species that they can go after
that are potentially easier I remember a
giraffe is a massive animal and can be
dangerous and difficult to get to in
open plains like this tall good eyesight
can see Lions coming when the grass is
short like this and so tricky to get
close to them
but in certain areas for sure I mean
there's prides
they win the mountain pride which was on
the sort of eastern side of the Kruger
National Park a little bit north of sabi
sands have yet to draw a straight line
to the Mozambique boundary the mountain
pride at one point so they were with
almost 40 to 42 lines somewhere there
and they were hunting giraffe almost
every day because that was sustaining
them and there was a large population of
giraffe so it really just depends on the
animal depends on the environment that
it's in its food availability all of
those kind of factors will dictate where
the giraffe are a key kind of components
in a lion's diets but mine is doing
sterling work isn't it quite something
what amazes me about that is that a
giraffe is a huge creature and it has
been dwarfed by those skies that we've
got this afternoon so it gives you an
idea just kind of how big the clouds and
how kind of open it feels sometimes when
you hear and and that's the kind of
things that people come a long way to
see is those kind of moments right there
Gary in terms of how big giraffe groups
gets also very variable here in the Mara
tend to be a little bit larger than what
we see from the juma the jhummer kind of
groups although in the sabi sands I have
seen a group of 17 here they tend to be
a lot more here used to in to see groups
of sometimes even as much as 20 which is
obviously quite a lot now it is starting
to rain so what I want to just do sorry
guys I have parked a little bit poorly
for the rain I'd park because of the
the rainbow but what I'm gonna do is
just need to just turn us down a little
bit because the way that I've got our
cupboard seats up if I have us a little
bit more like that's which actually
helps mana and helps him we open up the
giraffe and the Lions a little bit then
we're able to kind of keep the rain from
coming on us at all we don't actually
have to worry one bit now because we've
got one side of the car that's
completely closed so as long as the rain
doesn't come from the opposite direction
which it shouldn't given the way it's
been coming all afternoon then you
should be okay
I've just spotted another line this very
find the distance money you see her all
the way down now I don't know if she's
part of the pride because there was no
lines that we saw move in that direction
way off in the distance there is a lion
that is kind of sitting there watching
this grouping which is interesting
so I wonder because where we are now
could very well be the window of pride I
mean we know the pride that could be
here as well so it might even be one of
them that's around which is intriguing
so I'm wondering what she's going to do
she's just popped up now that the rain
has started to fall
it's definitely none of the members that
we saw this morning because pretty much
all of them are accounted for 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 although we didn't have
13 this money so maybe actually she
sneaked off and kind of gotten somewhere
down that side but interesting just
giving yourself a little shake because
of the rain that's falling might be able
to hear the rain that's kind of hitting
the roof at the moment now the one thing
we do have to be very careful of here
which is is lightning so as much as the
I don't mind rain lightning is obviously
a very big threats it's also a massive
threat to equipment so we need to be a
bit careful the Lightning gets any
closer we're gonna have to make a bit of
a call but we'll see yeah so far we're
okay let's just see how we got just a
few strikes right well I'm gonna just
see how this lightning goes we'll just
see how we kind of pan out but I'm gonna
send you across to Sydney who's still
looking for the elusive spots of jummah
now leaving the chitrashi rawat whole
area going back to Yuma as this side the
signs are not here and we have just seen
the signs on the other side of the Lyons
I want to go and check it from where my
camera operator spotted those Lion
tracks maybe our luck is on the juma
side
so here I have checked all the rules I
did a loop around the water hole and
there's still no sign of any of the
predator quite a lot of impalas in the
area so you can say you can see that for
DJ's are concentrating much more towards
the juma sides done and this side of
[ __ ] watch it WA
so somewhere here is where we saw those
tricks
Barbara that is what I'm hoping for
I am trying to heat the two birds with
one stone because the very same area
where the Lian tricks are is where
osanic got disappeared yesterday and
they still no sign of Hassan and no
updates on Hosanna since yesterday
so somewhere here is where we have lost
the tracks of that and lion let me just
check the ground thoroughly korsak's
unfortunately we haven't picked up any
Buffalo tracks yet so these lions might
be maybe after any kind of a game in the
area
yes their special preference is the
buffaloes but they do go and hunt for
something different
so the tricks are hitting much more left
side
thank you very much the good news maybe
I might bring you some good news with
these cats
so somewhere here
thank you so here we are the weather is
fine is unlike the Mara at the moment
yes on our side as well the weather is
building we might get some rain maybe
tonight or tomorrow the rain is always
unpredictable this morning le there was
a little bit of a shower and we are
hoping for more rain in the next two or
three weeks
so Tristan and my other colleagues in
the Maasai Mara they are now in the
middle of the rain
so I've got an Impala here at the moment
this Impala looks very healthy it's one
of the members of this bachelor head I
am seeing a bachelor head because all
the members I'm seeing here are carrying
horns so impalas you will see them
forming the breeding heads which is
consisted of the females and one
breeding male is a harem and you will
see them also in bachelor has young ones
of the same age you'll see them forming
a crash and some they become part of the
nazar head this is a nice Impala
short and thank you very much Craig look
at those black markings at the back and
also the black markings on the hind legs
this is quite a good just animal so you
can see the impalas got the three
different a Gary I agree this is a nice
Impala look at the side of the bodies
you can see those three colors which
break these animals into
three-dimensional shapes and this
confuse the Predators the most you know
the animals they employ the
anti-predator strategies normally these
anti predatory strategies are part of
what is called crypsis which is just a
strategy employed by the animals to
avoid the detection by the predator
these strategies are not perfect because
mostly they can only work when the
animal is not moving once the animals
start moving is going to destroy the
strategy and the predator is going to be
able to see it so the animals such as
the zebras those ones are clever because
they employ something called a dazzle
motion or is called a motion does does
the motion where when they're running is
when they are confusing the Predators so
they don't use that strategy when they
are stationary when they are running the
stripes dazzles and when the stripes are
doing that
they give the predator a contradictory
directional signals so they get confused
on where these animals is going and it's
always very difficult for a predator to
single one out
so are now less occurs over the Maasai
Mara aware at least tristant not Kristin
at Tristan is enjoying the Lions in the
rain indeed we do rain starts into fall
and our prayer lines as you can see
heads are starting to go into that
typical lion fashion where they start to
droop a little bit so they kind of look
through squinted glances and the ears
get sort of tucked in a certain way and
they look very unhappy with life so
that's where we're at at the moment
where guys are getting rained on and you
can see what we were talking about
earlier everyone is asking about rain
and whether or not they move or do they
not like it you can see it's raining now
and they haven't moved at all so they
haven't run to the tree you just know
that it's part and parcel so they're
just such air they take it and then they
hope that once it's done they can wake
up and start to kind of move around the
lioness that was far in the distance
still hasn't joined I can't see her
anymore but she hasn't arrived here so
that's gonna be interesting to see
whether or not she does start to move in
this direction and then this story is
one line is that is weighted not with
the group at the moment but the rain is
pelting down and for now these guys are
sitting I think if we had had a buffalo
herd here now eirick and we would have
maybe seen some action and seen them
starting to try and go after them they
often do hunt Buffalo in the rain but
with nothing really around other than
those giraffe which we've discussed is
not really on the list for the whole
hour losses as big giraffe go I mean if
it was a small draft maybe so they can I
think weighted out and as it gets a
little dark and after the rain it's gone
then I think we're gonna start to see
these guys moving about and starting to
kind of look for for some sort of food
which would be nice
[Applause]
but for now sleepy
ladybirds not that I've ever picked up
to be honest with you I mean they they
do have a slight smell to them but not
as strong as a wet dog it's not they're
not hugely smelly and it's funny you
often people think you know when you're
sitting around lines and all kinds of
animals actually hyena lion and wild
dogs well dogs are smelly but the rest
are not actually smelly at all unless
they've been feeding on an old carcass
then they they take on this one of the
carcass and all they passing gas but
otherwise they don't smell like wet dog
well certainly not strong enough that we
can pick up from the vehicle itself you
know at the moment these cats are
probably I would say but 10 to 15 meters
away from me at the moment and so you
know the smell from there to here with
the rain I won't pick it up at all I'd
have to really let go close and probably
touch it to activate that smell and
maybe then it would have that sort of
scent but from where I'm sitting now and
the way that we are no not at all I
can't smell any sort of wet dog smell
and I have never smelt it really on
Lions before there's a slight maybe a
slight kind of I don't know what the
smell is but it's not wet dog smell
there's a slight smell to it but it's
not it's not what you would think often
also remember when it rains in Africa
you get the smell of soil and things
like a dish off and overpowers these
guys at the distances that we're at I
think if we had to knock I say go and
rub up on them we'd probably get that
smell a lot more
[Applause]
ah the pitter-patter of rain a typical
Marr afternoon that's for sure
quite lucky that we can actually sit and
still film in this because this is quite
tricky conditions for a lot of for Juma
and even if it's lacking starts then
unfortunately we have to shut it down
between well now we're all good Marcy
well you asked a question that's
unfortunately the only one person can
really kind of a test to and that is
well you use the only one out of all of
our presenters to have seen wild dogs in
the Maasai Mara
so yes they are yeah these are packets
in Tanzania and a pack that's in
northern conservancies of the Mara and
sometimes very very rarely do they make
an appearance in the Triangle and after
two years of being here
basically all year in eight months if
you want to call it that
Mali was the one that actually got the
wild dogs running up the escarpment
which he was very excited about and I
thought he did a Stirling if it given it
was the first time he had gone live I
enjoyed it his excitement was infectious
and so the answer to it is yes but with
with caution that it's it's very rare
fair enough yes that would be a fair
statement
yes okay ma gives me the seal of
approval in sand if you get their
improvements and then you know all is
good so I believe a lot of you are
saying that your cats get very smelly
when they get wet so the thing is is
that I would like to know from many of
you do you smell your cats before they
kind of before you touch them
or do you just smell them because you
get up close to them it's an interesting
thing because lions like I say we
obviously the distance that we're at
very few people would be able to
probably smell the cats at the distance
that all we're at at the moment from
these lines so if I had to put your cats
from where I'm sitting I highly doubt
that I would smell them maybe maybe not
maybe I would I'm not quite sure the
interesting thing though is that you
know they're obviously is a stent to
them and maybe somebody that's ever I
don't know
worked with lions before I'll have to
ask some vets whether or not in rain
when they when they touch them less they
can smell them
but in the lines that I've been
fortunate enough to have worked with in
terms of fate starting and checking and
those kind of things and you can touch
them but generally you always touch them
with gloves and so that smell is never
really on your hands it's not like wild
dogs wild dogs I mean you do work around
them and if you touch them and you put
that on your codes that smell just
doesn't come out of your clothes for
days and you have to wash it a few times
until it starts to come out and your
hands as well so you know they are a lot
more smelly in what the lines are unless
the lines like I say I've been eating a
rotten carcass if they've been eating a
rotten carcass till then you'd your
tickets I think they smell horrendous
say crystal you say your cat doesn't
smell like anything when it's wet
compared to a dog in my experience in
the cats that I've had in my life
that would be the same for me I don't
really recall my cats smelling like wet
anything really maybe a little bit yes
can't remember
giraffe go you say you never really
smell your cats now giraffe go that
would be if anybody else was distinct
this conversation and wasn't really
paying attention to what has been going
on and just took that as a one-liner to
be a rather awkward thing to explain is
that I never really smelled my cats it's
a kind of weird one-liner
that people might kind of look at you
but funny is to say why are you talking
about smelling your cats anyway with it
and what are you doing that you are
picking up and smelling your cat so you
know funny things that we talked about
on well it's unsafe our ladders or from
getting to these funny conversations but
I'm glad that you don't smell your cats
I'm sure your cats quite happy you know
in cats they don't really like to be
picked up and smelt a lot of them
Jocelin have you got as Joslyn has gone
off to go smelly cats but now Justin I
want to know one thing before you go and
smell your cat you can't just pick up
and smell your cat because you've you
know just decided you want to smell it
and it's dry the experiment has to be
that the cat has got to be wet now
anyone who has ever tried to wet a cat
will know very well that that's not a
very good idea for the most part they
always Dodd cats out there that's not
two-phase but most cats don't like to be
wet so I'm intrigued to see how this
goes and whether or not you're
successful in the fact that you can slow
your cat initial course has been raining
where you are and then of course you
will be able to do it but otherwise your
experiment is going to be a bit flawed
or you are going to make your cat wait
and that's going to be probably
detrimental to some form of your body
you it's going to get cold at some point
so let us know how it goes and if there
is any cawing that takes place send us a
photo it will be quite funny to see
what's your cats actually looks like and
if you do wet your cat the faces of a
wet cat is generally quite miserable so
a screen shot of your cats with
quite funny as well but hopefully you're
not gonna wait you're captain Rachael
cat cats don't like to be wit conceived
these cats are not to it they'll shake
off all of them to snarl and you'll find
a little water will come off them it's
bait so in the male's do it because they
get the mains and the mains get a lot
waiter but these guys are pretty cool
too to see as well right well our lines
slowly stirring so while we see if
they're gonna wake up let's send you
back across the city and see if he's had
any luck with his lines will happen I am
still busy checking for these cats and
it is quiet here where I am and no
tracks on the road at all all I'm seeing
all the tracks for this morning a lot of
Viners activities here showing that eNOS
has been here maybe designers way after
other lepers
so these days is going to be very
difficult to spot an animal from the
bushes without seeing the track first
so maybe we might be lucky with some of
the fresh tracks I'm going to try the
Milwaukee area princedom area
can pick up a very strong smell
a child of the universe the lions don't
specifically target an animal after the
Buffalo they target they profess
something which is heavier than 550 550
kilograms so if something is larger than
550 kilograms is preferred by the Lions
so in other words Lions they first check
the size of the group if they see that
the size of the pride is 10 like the
unko Houmas or 11 they know they must
have to duck at something big so that
everyone can get satisfied here comes
the problem Lions they know if they
don't target something big to satisfy
everybody it is going to be like a
fruitless exercise they don't want to
lose much energy in order to get a
little bit of food they want to change
something big and lose energy in order
to gain back the energy they have lost
and I think is a good idea
so now I am going to send you to the
Maasai Mara
where David is also looking for
something in the rain well ladies and
gentlemen I can say I have a smile on my
face because for the last 30 40 minutes
me and Archie has been hammered by very
heavy storms and at one point we just
had to stop the vehicle you can see how
it great looks
we stopped the vehicle and we don't know
where to go left all right but at least
you see we've just brought all the flaps
down
we are still surviving you're still in
business and where we are now is a lot
better well in the process of us being
hammered by the rain we saw black rain
unfortunately that was my mission for
today but also the Rhino was equally
confused to like us because she kept
running hot tail up and this is
something that will happen well in the
way that just changes it drastically now
we have elephants at the moment and what
will happen is unlike other animals
which panic or which grow in a bit of
confusion when it rains out of my many
years in the bush I have noticed
elephants they just keep doing the thing
if they were feeding they'll just keep
pinning the only one time I see
elephants slow down stall is the mid of
the heat of the day and especially they
have young cuffs like that when you see
them they might look for some shade
under some huge trees but when it's just
no more cold temperatures rain or no
rain the elephants are always on the
move and that translates to elephants
being my favourite animals because it's
very unusual to see an elephant just
doing nothing and just like boring you
and not doing an action well remember
this is a very interactive Safari we are
on regardless of the rain should you
have any comments or any questions who
are you why is it raining where you are
then we're Tristan is would be happy to
talk to you hashtag Safari live on
Twitter well I was talking earlier
saying these are the short rains but it
would happen they might turn out to be
again
long range like what we had ally in the
and when we stopped you the Archie at
one point not sure had a little clip of
the rain there I don't know that you
want to come to me for a couple of
seconds and I sure this the viewers can
see that the garage
yeah I mean the final control says oh my
goodness that sauce one and before
things got better
well the visibility at one point was
even poor we could not even move and we
stuck in that one area and we thought
you're gonna stay here until things get
better and go out so what you did when
we have done a very big detour
Christel very good comment and you're
saying it's raining elephants and
buffaloes and not cats and dogs that's a
great comment I've always wanted to use
the same comment because this is not
what you call cats and dogs
this truly is elephants and buffalos or
we might say giraffes and rhinos just
like the one Rhino voiceover what other
thing is the buck in business it's not
as heavy as it was before this village
is still not as good so we're going to
be maybe assembling our infrared maybe
in a few minutes who doesn't get any
better and finding out what you might
see on the road
John we get tornadoes or what kind of
very big storms luckily in Africa we do
not we do not get tinnitus we do not get
those natural listenings but sometimes
when it rains we get very heavy rains
and what happens is when there is a very
heavy they damage the infrastructure
roads and communication in Brooks breaks
down but we luckily do not get tinnitus
in Africa not silly like what maybe
people would get it in North America so
I am counting on you to support game for
me because at the moment my visibility
is almost less than 10% I can only see
about 5 meters in front of me and your
cenotes our cars have almost no what you
found over there the wipers on the
windshield because we always tilt the
windshield in on the bonnet
Paula I'm very careful Paula and always
very good to hear your name and
hopefully Paula you can see I have my
shoe Kavya so what I'm doing today I am
staying on the big road I'm really
surgical m25 I am NOT leaving this
highway I would stick here and to the
drives over but the biggest mistake or
the biggest risk I gonna do is try to
deviate and come out of the road to go
get close to an animal what happens here
in the Mara the geology of the Mara the
soil here it's very easy tikki we have
work to cut the black cotton soil and if
it rains that one can put you in a lot
of trouble so possibly stay on the big
road where they got some nice you know
compact soil that just keeps you afloat
and you don't want to think
last night I was stuck for about 10
minutes on the last night are are they
even in game drive
so just surely but the times your team
cuts come on the road went rain so
heavily and the grass become very wet
lions in general or the cheetahs for
example they do not like the wetness of
the grass and they tend to come to the
road Albert the roads being wet will
prefer staying on the road than in the
grass hi
Parliament is stunning everything green
and everything turns green the
herbivores have every reason to
celebrate the cards the same and I'm
hoping this rains are still in Serengeti
National Park we are looking at another
12 half months or so they will be
springing down there baby's butts are on
the map of February
all the tall glass patrols here couple
of months ago became in the big
multitude and the lawn mowed everything
and the government is very short the
only animals enjoying the animals all
the grass would be the Buffaloes
giraffes eland
and some other smaller until our they
Luke sake in South Africa with Sydney
and I'm sure he might be trying to get a
leopard or a cane of some cuts
a DVD here where I am the bush is also
completely green and this bush was fast
to recover everything is green and is
very much thick at the moment I am
trying my is to see if we got any of the
cats this afternoon I've just been in
need finish there now now except for the
avian group every each and every water
hole here
yeah
sorry for the apologies for the
inconvenience
we are brilliant thing and some more
technical issues we will be back just
now
the signals coming and going and going
so now let's see maybe we might oh look
at that
oh look at that
oh that all decided oh another one day
oh they were all sitting here and
they've just left just now so it was the
two hours I'm not too sure what they
were busy with and so now let's go to
the Masai Mara where David is waiting
well some of these things will happen
and I remember at one point today
I lost you'd imagine what we do in terms
of technology to get us to your screen
back home there is quite a complex way
of doing things
personally I enjoy the rain and I have
nothing against the rain when I come
from any day or where I come from in my
village and it a the rain should come my
mother tell you know what you look so
excited today and I'll tell her I can
see the clouds building in the clouds
building woods maybe translate some
rains later and when it would rain all
of us should go out with all the other
boys and what he used to do we'd run and
just stop in the middle of the mud and
just slide you know and it was so funny
would compete pool would slide more than
the other and the only challenges or the
challenges were you go back home with a
few injuries in there we used to get
very big beatings from our parents like
what did you do where did you go you
know
those are the things that should happen
then and even today I still enjoy the
rain yes and you know in the final
control says that was quite some fun but
apparently no garden
the first time you say you love the rain
- and would not love rain what do you
think
what's rain translates into I mean
everybody should you know love the rain
like the locos here or we come from in
the villages where we need to go to the
rivers or streams to get the water when
she dries up it's a challenge for the
you know the villagers they are because
it will mean them going longer distances
to go to the bigger rivers to get the
water but if it rains it's all green we
have so many streams - most villages in
Africa or they can easily go and fetch
water either for cooking or for laundry
I'm still hoping to see some lions or
some cats of some sort on the road
because the surface is much drier than
the grass which looks pretty wet for me
now or maybe we get some elephants
walking on the roads the drafts also
don't get very both fed by the rain
zebras are still fine with that it's
mainly moisture the animals does have
long path because they don't want any
water the fire does not fit or they
don't feel very good if they are far
whole lots of water
I'll be imagine also the cuts like lions
should get maybe pneumonia or they'll
get some infection or a cold once in a
whole and we have been out on the drive
is the particular pride of lions that
they call the sausage III pride that I
really love their massive right and the
times when I'm watching them logistic
cubs once the whole just sniffing you
know dude sneeze or cough and or imagine
is when maybe they inherit cold air or
when it gets very cold at night or if
it's ranged definitely is not very hard
to for them
big animals I will select the Buffaloes
I don't think they have issues you know
with the rain that should be good for
them
but David very good question and
apparently we share the same name and
I'm sure that's one of the best names in
the world I have ever heard of and you
want so the annual rainfall in tomorrow
it's about a thousand millimeter
annually
it's about 1000 millimeter that's the
annual rainfall tomorrow but I would say
this year we might be going one and a
half times starts maybe fifteen hundred
millimeters of rain David
this year because the rains weather the
long rains March every May and June and
they were very very heavy we had very
few trucks that should come out stave it
into again Drive and what you call short
rains now me equivalent to the normal
long range that we get every year so if
we double that or we say one and a half
times we might end up with about 1500
millimeter of rainfall this year well
since you've still got 20 more days or
15 days to the end of the year
all right any liens on the road here or
any hyenas not much
so what it do
Kagura you're asking does it ever get so
wet and the Safari vehicles have issues
yes like the months I'm talking about
June July it was so bad as so bad
because the vehicles mostly Safari
tourists are to stay on the big roads
like this and they watched a lion show
cheaters from a distance and the only
hard use the afar Lucas or by not
classism I feel guides who watch while
they take a risk
some of them was stuck for I wasn't ours
you know because you had to wait for big
grader could come and throw them out
and their times went even those great
ass who try to tow those vehicles out
and what should happen is it was very
difficult and the tour of the use
they'll snap so they ended up putting
the tourists on top of those graders and
I'm imagining something like an open
truck table with you know the tour is
holding the hunt bugs of the Apostles
and thereby no class is bein brought too
big a road like this and then they'll be
fetched by another vehicle back to the
camp you know of course the Hemi those
who accompany them and they go back to
the camp either have a long breath first
or stain have lunch and wait for what
day or two to go back and tell the
vehicle out
yeah it was very tough it was very tough
hopefully doesn't get to that level
this time around we highly doubt but
you're waiting to hear from the motor
logical Department and they're gonna
tell us how it will be but I can tell
you for a fox the last 5-10 years
the weather pattern here has been quite
erratic very difficult to say tomorrow
this is what we expect next week this
would expect no no no sometimes you just
wait and play by the
well it said so jisub side was they
coming back again but so long as I stay
on the big road I'll still be in
business
very good fingers crossed doesn't get
pretty bad but does it say the good news
is the surface on this road is very
compact tutorial and everything is
pretty fine this doesn't worry me a
minute what should happen if it gets
very big and we get thunderstorms or
lessening we may only have to power down
and wait for things to get better but as
far as we are concerned at this point in
time so far so good and still in
business the only thing I want is to get
some lions or something on the roads and
I'm sure I can swim one side or the
other and Archie will open his small new
window and you might see it
we'll keep driving enjoying the rain
enjoying the darkness and Sydney I don't
know whether he would want to be here or
would want to be where he is
I wish that rain was here a so very hard
here by the mallanna province at the
moment during the night is so warm so I
think if the rain comes to this side of
the world we are going to enjoy because
it's gonna get much cooler so I'm going
back to the cheetah hotline and see if
maybe we cannot be lucky with anything
coming out from the church wood as at
the moment it looks like there's quite a
lot of things happening by the Torchwood
side as it is the same area ting Ghana
was last spotted calamba is always there
Chandi has been spotted there now husana
we saw him yesterday going to the same
area so I think it's ideal going to
double-check the cheetah hotline
we want all these cats to come back to
the side of Duma
so the interesting thing is where we are
going to look at now the fire break is
much more clear and the roads are much
more open so it's very easy to pick up
their tracks
Elaine I didn't copy your question very
nicely
the most effective camouflage of these
animals I can say the best one is the
dazzle motion as I indicated which is
the one for the Zebras that one I think
it works more effectively that's why
zebras they don't really get affected by
predation by this Lyell they do get
caught but not very often despite the
heavy kick as the Zebras they've got a
very dangerous kick and ten mechanism
when they are turning to the right they
kick to the left when they are turning
to the left
they kick to the right
so they can kick very well the zebras
and they also got a very strong bite
something is important that I also as
check at this side we have been here
before we drove here but I just want to
check this area for the second time as
now the Sun is about to go down and when
the Sun is going down is when the
Perdita such as the leopard are starting
to become much more active maybe is when
they will be coming out from coach would
to us at the gym aside
so I have seen the fresh droppings of
one Buffalo in the middle of the
Milwaukee drainage line maybe that is
the Buffalo which obstructed the Lion
tracks we have seen earlier
maybe or sauna got something deep in the
Torchwood side yesterday that's why it's
not coming out we are not seeing any of
the sign of him in the area
he was really on a hunting mood
yesterday so I saw him I have witnessed
him trying to catch stn back so now that
the impalas are having quite a lot of
lamps a polar I have not yet seen the
chameleons yet but now is when the
chameleons are active I have seen one
chameleon on the road outside the
reserve on my way back from the leaf but
here I have not yet noticed one maybe
they are just very calm of late
so no luck by the eastern side of the
cheetah cutline so which means now I'm
gonna have to drive all the way up much
more toward buffers hook again to see if
there is no other tracks by the cheetah
cut line so the difference between me
and David is that I am driving where is
dry and David is driving in the rain so
let's have experience of both these game
drives
how interesting to have two different
walls one with rain and one very dry
we're sitting knees and I'm wondering
whether it is a twisting or 100 achieve
because it's not me who did the rain
dancer and once you do the rain dog this
is exactly what happens I suppose that
you I'm not sure he is hearing me or
he's just ignoring me but it's very
strange we get rains here but not as big
I remember way back in my village my
grandfather tell me the times when it
was very dry and if those big drought
people had plants of trying to bring the
rain and what they did they would forget
one particular ship and that ship had to
be only one color one color I'm saying
if it was black it wasn't even one five
not one here that could be white it was
spotless block and if it was white it
was spotless white and nicely the eyes
were white but it was meant to be only
one color and one they'll do your
particular trees they would go and make
a ritual near those trees and those
trees what she calls a fig trees I'm
sure all of you know the fig trees and
there were particular elders there were
particular people in the village who
could only do that
not every other you know Tom and Dick
and Harry will do that so the particular
elders and the villagers would go to
them and beseech them you know this
drought is so bad no or chop our aunt
was dying we are going hundreds of miles
look for you know water to fetch for
cooking or laundry you need to do that
ritual so the moment will get a couple
of those sheep be it five or ten I can't
remember how many our hood they'll get
them together
and this elders would drive this ship
towards those fig trees and or they do
don't go under those trees and they'll
slaughter them and they did not touch
any meats from what is orchard and all
the stomach contents would be spread
around those trees and the particular
prayers you know they would make
although a particular way they'll talk
either to the traditional God or I can't
remember what and that process was
taking about I hear a day or two and as
soon as they finish to do that they'll
start heading back to the village and
what I gathered or what I remember is
before even don't leave the Ridgeway
area where the heart
the sacrifice is done before even though
the start you know preparing to go back
deep oats a thunderstorm
would you come the next thing you'd hear
or see were letterings
and the truth is before they'll get back
to the village the heavens would have
opened and it would rain I'm sure I
can't remember who told me I'd dog I
mean no not dogs and cats it should be
raining buffaloes and elephants and
truly the dynamics the ball game would
change lots of rain and jute and green
in a very short time and the villagers
to be like well done to those elders no
schwa what about to happens today I do
not know and the times I've always
thought well can I go and try it
hola I agree with you and I think
dancing the shower could be something
very special so I do not know I mean
polo whether I would be able to do the
same today myself but I wish to draw to
try not shoe I have the right edge but
the people Paula would blow that were
particular you know elders wolves easily
do that the only other thing for I
remember we do instead of going to the
river all to the dams to bathe ourselves
or just in the rain you know without
clothes on
excuse my language and rain would fall
on us and using some my leaves for the
widow from the bush which could measly
make some form and just bet in the rain
and come back home in the village being
very clean boys you know and our mothers
to just look at us like this shake their
heads and the only one thing I remember
my mother used to tell me she doesn't
want to hear anybody cough if you cough
go back in the rain just spend the night
out there and I don't know whether
today's children are able to do the same
and I'm thinking we were either less
than 10 years old swayback
well you're still soldering on the reins
haven't stopped the app knots and
relenting they still keep hammering us
and we're gonna keep trying to chance on
anything on the road
actually how you doing back there
arch is just going like this I'm not
sure what that means but sir
we're gonna keep trying in the rain but
I think that the gentleman who is
driving in the very dry weather I am
right on the a cheetah cut line where I
am not seeing any of the sign of any of
this cat here but I'm gonna just keep
going and going until I now check the
buffers who cut line maybe we might be
lucky much more to us a buffer to cut
line
oh I'm lucky with a cocktail jungle you
can see the Fox you're drunk
look at that background how nice is
looking nice and green so the [ __ ]
children go look at the tail it's like a
fork and this is one of those birds who
does eat quite a lot of insects and even
youth strategies such as mimicking some
of the Predators just to get rid of the
other birds to avoid competition in the
area saying was too fast to fly away
I've got to carry on now and see if we
can find any other interesting animal
Ashley it is so green both grasses and
trees are so excited at the moment if
you look at this grasses here on my
right-hand side you can see how green
that is this grass when the animals are
feeding on it they don't get pressurized
at all at the moment because the animals
cannot concentrate on a specific place
but when animals are concentrating by
the same block every time it gives the
grass quite a lot of pressure and
instead of some of the grasses to grow
instead of the some of the grasses to
grow up they lie down
so now let's cross over to the Maasai
Mara where Tristan is ready to come back
well unfortunately we've had a few
gremlins of our own and that means that
we've been kind of following these lines
for a little bit today unfortunately our
hitting in turn area we're not gonna be
able to follow them which is a shame I
was hoping that they weren't going to go
the way they've gone but they these guys
are for now sitting back these are the
last three everybody else has already
gone they're going straight up the
escarpment put up a kind of forested
section that cuts into the escarpment
and it is impossible to follow through
there so it's not even we're not even
gonna try to even follow them much
further than yeah I'm hoping that these
three boys will stand up and start mean
I think it's boys difficult to see ma'am
well I can't see anything is obviously
just whatever the camera sees itself but
these guys are for some reason very
intrigued by something they all stop
there and they all kind of rolled around
and have had a good time bonding over
there now Brendon will the olive oil
meals for sub-adults form coalition's
yes provided they all survive so
provided the kitchen boys don't get
overthrown and new males come in within
the next two years we year and a half
and then they should form a coalition
how many in each coalition would be
interesting it I mean if if seven of
them which is what I counted this
morning apparently there is nine but
I counted seven Oni if there's seven of
them then that is a big coalition and
whether they stick together I'm not sure
if they do they will rule this entire
triangle really because they won't have
much competition but what often happens
when you get big coalition's like that
particularly at that times of the year
where is the migrations not here food
for that many big males is rate tricky
to find as well as the distribution of
the females makes it you know almost
impossible for the seven of them to stay
together all the time and so what you'll
get is probably splitting off of maybe
two or three year I'm going in their own
directions and forming some two or three
coalition's and then every now and then
kind of coming together and separating
art the only ones that really have kind
of been big big big coalition's like
that in the Mara has been the Musketeers
notch and Sons was a big coalition as
well but I don't think there's been a
coalition of seven has there and maybe
I'm wrong I mean I could be wrong you
know there's a rich history in the Mara
that's long before my time so there
might have been a coalition of seven or
more but certainly haven't heard about
them so you know it's gonna be tough for
seven males to survive together and like
I say that just the amount of females
will end the smallness of a lot of the
prides within the triangle mean that
you'll probably find that they'll split
apart quite a bit spending lots of time
is twos or threes or on their own and
then come together they're much like the
Musketeers do if you see the Musketeers
is very seldom that they spend huge
amounts of time is all four
in Francis good question actually I'm
not sure to be honest with you I would
imagine lines I'm play with lines name
have better eyesight in the dark than
hyenas but I might be wrong do they have
a tortoise or something that they eating
hold on let's get a little bit closer
money I think they might be eating a
tortoise imagine it's a Pangolin money
with no vehicle it's definitely
something that they've chomping on here
so I'm just using my lights so I can
actually see where I'm going what are
you two boys chomping on it's thing that
is round and big what is it is it a
pendulum it looks like a pendulum it is
a Pangolin
it's a Pangolin look at that guys that's
ridiculous so the lines are busy playing
with a Pangolin no what are the chances
that's crazy now this is a super super
rare animal and what are the chances
I've been playing with a Pangolin no I
don't believe it
that is ridiculous now am i we can I
think we should take this to a lot more
people because one is it is incredibly
special animal to to see Lions playing
with it is even more rare so this is
something that we are not going to get
very often at all and I hope that
they're not going to leave it alone now
because it's rolled into a tight ball to
defend itself or this is insane look at
that can you hear the claws on its
scales
no I can't believe our luck this is
amazing
Wow now Pangolin has got to be besides a
lipid it got to be one of my favorite
animals and not something that we get to
see often at all in fact we very very
very very seldom see one no don't leave
it now line because I want to show
people and know the Lions have lifted
missus Lapwing he has been playing
soccer now let's see if the Penguins
okay should be okay when they roll up
like that they going to be kind of
together now it's actually my fault
because I was so far away that it didn't
notice that that's what they had found
that is ridiculous now come on little
one you're gonna have to unroll at some
point so that we can see you this is
insane guys this is a penguin that is
only the second one we've ever ever ever
gotten live on camera there last one was
with brain T and he had it and I was
actually inside the Kruger National Park
so this is very special rights now I
think we can go live anyway even though
it's not moving let's try and see it
will come out unfold it eventually it's
not going to stay like that favorite
just probably thinks the Lions are still
around so we can still go live and we'll
discuss the whole thing while the lines
are still close by
well good evening everybody and welcome
to the Maasai Mara and with a very very
very special animal we've just managed
to find a Pangolin which is curled up in
a very tight ball at the moment and the
reason why is because lions were
actually playing with it we didn't
realize what the Lions had and we drove
up and they had found this Pangolin and
they were trying to chew into the
penguin but it was too kind of curled up
and it's armour plating was too tough
for it and so the Lions have moved off
and we've sat with the penguin now in
the hope that it's going to start
unraveling and we'll start to get it to
move now penguins are an incredible
animal they're not something that we get
to see very often at all in fact they're
an animal that is incredibly rare as the
most trafficked animal in the world
these days and so they are vitally
important that we actually when we get
to see one which is like I say extremely
rare this is only the second time that
we've managed to get a Pangolin on this
particular product that we produce in
almost 10 years so that gives you an
idea of how rare these guys are they are
not common at all and so the thing is is
that they are used for these scales now
let's see if it's going to move I
thought I saw it just twitch slightly
what you'll find with these guys is they
roll up into this defensive ball and
they've got this long tail so the tail
is what's closest to us at the moment
very difficult to make out and what's
actually going on but the tail is
closest to us and it rolls round and
protects their head and the head tucks
in and those hard scales will protect
the soft underbelly where the legs and
the face is so that they don't get hurt
when things like lions come across them
because they're not fast animals and
this does happen
nori can it breathe like that yes so if
you have a look it's it's a bit tricky
to see bits in the middle of that there
you'll see that there's a sort of
contour which is the the tail coming
round and in it this is almost like a
little gap that goes down now that's is
where the actual kind of face will be
and so there is air getting in there and
they can breathe I've luckily seen quite
a few pangolins in my time and every
time they roll up like this they can't
stay like this for quite a long time
particularly if lions have been around
and they will just curl up and they wait
and they wait and they wait and only
when they really sure that the Lions are
gone they might even be curled up
because I'm talking at the moment and
when they really showed that the Lions
had disappeared will they then unravel
themselves and they'll start to move and
it is an amazing thing that we are I
can't actually believe that we've
managed to find a penguin when we saw
the lines kind of messing around I
thought maybe they've gotten a tortoise
but tortoises aren't out at night and so
I thought maybe just maybe there's a
Pangolin and we have flat one which is
insane so very very cool now I forgot to
introduce myself as well my name is
Justin and on camera I've got some man
who this evening and we are coming to
you live which means we want to hear
from all of you so remember to be able
to sing through your questions and
comments and two out of the comments
section below and will basically answer
as many as we can
giraffe go what is the main diet of a
Pangolin well penguins will spend their
time feeding mostly of things like
termites ants where they have will
basically go along they've got these
four limbs that almost look a little bit
like t-rex when they walk so they're on
their back legs to front legs and they
have long claws and the claws they'll
then scrape at the mounts and they open
it up and then they have this tongue
that is pretty much the length of their
body so it almost attaches close to
their back legs their hips and it kind
of comes out and it will go down and
it's very sticky and it will pull out
those little insects and bring them back
into the mouth and they'll in feed off
that and so that's probably why this one
is out today after the bit of rain that
we've had that's going to mean that it's
going to going to show the soils can be
softer much easier to dig I just want to
move slightly so you can see if maybe we
can just get a view of any Lions that
might be around the Lions look like they
kind of moved off unfortunately into the
distance they got fed up of trying to
kind of go towards this Pangolin and try
to sort of eat it now they went off in
that distance there you can see as a bit
of rain that's falling I'm gonna use my
spotlight just to give money a bit of
help but unfortunately the Lions have
really disappeared last one I saw is
walking there just before we went to all
of you we just saw it disappearing over
this Ridge
so Graham you're asking where in the
Mara am I well I'm in the Mara triangle
basically straight below and gamma Mara
so and the northern points
of the martyr triangle so there is our
penguin I'm going to just move slightly
so that man you can actually get a
better views we can show you a bit more
of the details because at the moment
we're in a bit of a tricky spot with the
grass so we're just gonna get I know I'm
gonna go round a little bit so that we
can see a bit better so we're a little
bit higher than what the grass is we
should be able to see a little bit
better so yeah Graham we're right up in
the north
there we go now crystal are penguins
nocturnal not strictly they are active
more at night so they do like to move
around a lot in the evenings because
it's a lot easier for them to go and
they don't get harassed and spotted as
easily but they are not strictly
nocturnal they can be seen during the
day and I have seen of the this is now
my 8 from 9th Pangolin that I've seen
two of them
we're during the day the rest of all
being at night so funny enough out of
the Penguins that I've seen to have been
accosted by lipids and this one now by
lions and you can see that armour
plating normos looks like a pinecone and
that you can see here and basically that
armour plating is like your fingernail
but incredibly thick so if you had to go
and kind of touch that it almost feels
like oh man you can knock on it and it
would be very very hard and that's why
the Lions actually leave it alone is
because their mouths just can't get a
purchase on it is because of the
hardness and specially tonight when it's
wet so it's slippery and they the teeth
are just gonna slide on that keratin
kind of armor plating and that's why I
eventually they're just going to leave
it alone they get frustrated and move on
both so penguins are solitary only see
them by themselves unless of course they
have a pup which will mean that they
have the little baby and often the baby
rides on their back which is super cute
that little baby Pangolin is the cutest
little thing in the world and they'll
ride on the back of mom but you're
solitary otherwise you won't see them in
pairs unless of course you very
fortunate and you find mating penguins
which is well then you must go play the
lottery that night because you're gonna
get very lucky
so Stephanie it's obviously very
difficult for you to be able to get any
idea of a sense of scale before these
guys and so basically in terms of size
if it was to unravel and to basically
stand and and it have its tail dead
straight and its nose out it would be
probably from the dashboard so from
about there to the end of the dashboard
so there abouts what's that
maybe my arm's length so just over about
a meter from the tip of the tail now I
actually do have a photo of one that I
can show you in there and Revels now
this particular species that we're
seeing I'm just trying to see where I
can get a photo for you this particular
species is called a Timmons ground
Pangolin which is the species that you
get here in East Africa down towards
South Africa you get them then in the
Congo and and forest areas of South
Africa I mean out of Africa sorry you
will get black build pangolins tree
pangolins and so a few other different
species as well Kathy they are voracious
you have to be very careful they all
attack you at the moment now I'm
checking there well not attack a person
they are all completely harmless to
people so basically and that's what
makes them a bit of why they so
threatened is because they don't really
have any defence people come across this
animal it's got nothing that it can do
other than roll into a ball like this
now which works really well for
predators that are natural to them but
as people obviously you know we can we
can get through that and so no they
don't release any sort of gas they don't
release any sort of substance that can
burn your skin or anything like that the
only thing they can do is roll in this
ball but I will tell you something is if
you pick them up and they agitate it
what they do is they want to survive
break their body and those scales move
and they actually can lacerate your
hands quite quickly you can see how
chipped and broken those scales are and
that's all kind of going to cut you up
if you try and pick them up so normally
what happens is people grab them with
bags into bags and then they they take
them out of the reserves illegally and
then from there normally is they are
boiled whole like this and in the scales
are pulled off and used so it's a bit of
a
a problem and like I said they are the
most trafficked animal in the world
currently which is pretty scary so it's
a horrible thing to think that we've got
animals out here that are being poached
at the rate that they are and tons and
tons and tons of Pangolin scales are
leaving Indonesia and Africa every every
year Xavier you asking if they related
to armadillos well no not really they're
not the same species armadillo has a
kind of softish body in comparison to
these guys so they're in their own
little grouping altogether now I'm
trying to find okay there we go so I
found a photo of it that I can show you
guys I just want to quickly adjust the
brightness so that we can actually see
my phone is decided because it's dark
that it must have a very low brightness
so we'll just try to get that up there
we go okay so basically this is what
these guys look like when they are
unraveled so they're very very scaly and
you can see a long long long tail now
that tail needs to be long one to
balance them because they walk on their
back legs only you see their front legs
are carried forward almost like a t-rex
and in this back tail will actually wrap
around like we're seeing now to protect
this animal they know if you have a look
I'll try a zoom in onto this one sorry
this is not a higher is a picture but we
can zoom in a little bit you can see
there on its front feet very very big
long claws tiny little ear smallish kind
of eye and then a long snout and that's
tongue will come out of that snot there
and they'll then pick it up and go back
in which is absolutely amazing
to see one of these is the most special
thing in the whole world and so we're
being so so spoiled I know it doesn't
look like much and I know it's just a
ball in the grass to some people but the
thing is is as a guide now spending 10
years out in the wilderness is of
various parts of Africa to only have
seen 8 or 9 of them in that time gives
you an idea of how rare they are and I
spend pretty much all day every day out
in the bush even when I'm on leave and
not working I mean some sort of Game
Reserve somewhere so it gives you an
idea how rare they are they are certain
places where you can go and you'll find
them and you'll have a bit more of a
success rate but they are an incredibly
special animal and very few people get
the opportunity to see
one of these things it is it's one of
those animals that you kind of wish that
you could see and then that you get
lucky enough to see now there's
apparently we're in a reserve that I've
worked before they reckon met with
pangolins that this is how they do
they'll curl up like this if they've
been attacked by a predator and they sit
like this and if you're talking and
those kind of things they stay like that
as soon as you if you want them to move
they always say that you start your car
now I'm not sure that that's true
because we started our car just now and
it didn't move it just decided to stay
killed up I think it's got the fright of
its life and I would too if I had had 13
lines on top of me as well at one point
so there was I think at one point there
was six of them but like I said we had
no idea what they were doing they just
look like they were grooming each other
and it couldn't really see what was
actually going on and so I was kind of
thinking to myself you know they
grooming quite a lot and then I some of
them started to leave and others stayed
behind and I thought no there's
something wrong here because lions
typically if one goes they may all start
to get up and start to move around but
yet this one kind of a lot of them
stayed behind and so I thought to myself
well maybe it's something else that
they've managed to find and so we kind
of came a little bit closer and it was a
penguin which is crazy
now I call it the life span for these
guys tricky they saw understudied but
reckoned to be about twenty years so I'm
anywhere between sort of eighteen and
twenty years would be about the right
lifespan for these guys but like I say
because they're so shy and so reclusive
there's so little that really known
about penguins and there's only a
handful of people that have actually
studied this particular species of
Pangolin with any sort of success and
and because it's around at night it
makes it even more tricky to find and
the one guy that did study them was a
guy that worked in the sabi sands Game
Reserve in South Africa and where Arjuna
bases and he used to have to go out at
night on foot so now this guy was crazy
his name is Jonathan SWAT and he's
written them some really interesting
stuff about penguins but used to go out
on foot and used to track penguins that
he had tagged and he would walk around
at night with a spotlight by himself now
you walk around in the bush it is not a
very pleasant experience
you got to walk through elephants
leopard lion hyenas just to follow these
guys around and so it makes it
incredibly tough and the problem with
them is that they spend an advanced
majority of their time hanging around
and so money is just having a little
scan trying to see if the lines are
anywhere near the vast majority of their
time moving and darker conditions and so
they also move in places we ain't
vehicles of going to really struggle to
go and so unfortunately you know they
they're one of those species that it's
very tricky to actually be able to study
and so that's why there's very little on
it but I actually can't believe that
we've seen a Pangolin tonight like I
like I say it's not the most riveting in
terms of its movements but to be able to
see this is so special now Connor what
is the rarest species of Pangolin
probably oh I mean I I read an article
about this the other day and because
they so sort of understudied apparently
it's I think it's the black bellied I
might be wrong so I have a black belly -
a white belly penguin one of the two of
them that is the rarest if I'm correct
I'm I'm just going to double check that
though but this particular one here is
not as sort of high up on the list of
rarities they are quite widespread and
there's probably a lot more of these
than we even know it's just when you
drive along not many people are going to
spot that in Ross like this we just
leave fortunate that Lions played with
it otherwise the chances of us seeing
this thing would have been almost zero
in the grass when it's curled up like
that it looks just like a rock in during
the day you would have zero idea that
that is a Pangolin unless of course
you've got close enough that you could
see the scales and so they've easily
overlooked and so actual numbers of
Pangolin are probably not as well known
now here in these environments we've got
cross rooms where we can probably spot
them a bit easier but you miss remorse
in the jungle areas penguins can be very
tricky to find so you know it's it's an
interesting animal in that regard and I
don't think numbers are really as
well-known as what people say they are
there's certainly a lot that are missing
alright unfortunately it's still curled
up it's probably still absolutely
petrified by the Lions and so we waited
and we tried and hope that it would get
up and start moving if it does start to
move we will go live again but from I
know myself and a very very special
sighting of a penguin it's been an
absolute pleasure hopefully you enjoyed
it and we'll see you guys again sometime
soon
well absolutely ridiculous now I know
that's you a lot of people might think
that I'm absolutely mad that I've gotten
so excited about a big bowl of scales in
a bush it doesn't look like very much
but I can tell you that they are really
really really quite special and
hopefully I mean I know a lot of you
will without doubt be completely
completely blown away that we've gotten
one I know a lot of you have really
asked to see pangolins over and over
again and I know we often laugh about it
and we say there's no chance but there
we go and I hope lots of screen shots
were taken when the Lions were playing
with it because it's a very special
thing to see that and and we've been
actually spoiled now this penguin has a
friend is a mock that is about the only
action that keeps seen from this penguin
that keeps bounding around on it and I'm
hoping it is going to and revel I don't
think it's hurt by the Lions before
anybody thinks that it's dead I don't
think that's the case I just think that
what's happened is it's it's so kind of
been played with so much that it just
feels very nervous and it can probably
still hear me talking and that's why
it's like this and it's just sitting and
it's really kind of feeling as though
it's being a bit kind of surrounded by
something and so maybe if we just you
know stop talking for a little bit and
said quietly never know if maybe just
maybe this little creature will actually
come out right now sorry I mean you
broke up badly I lost you a little bit
there so if you can just repeat what you
said
right good so we're gonna send you
across to David we're gonna sit quietly
in the hope that it starts to move and
if it does move then we'll come right
back but how special was that
well just like Sydney I think that was a
super special sighting and I'm very
jealous of a twister you know
Tristan might believe in the next few
days down to South Africa and he's been
here for about three weeks and he found
me here looking for fumblings and
pangolins and he has seen one before me
I am a little jealous but sometimes
she's the luck of the draw and being at
the right place at the right time and to
see one you know Alliance playing with
one another super special
anyhow pangolins RC might have said tend
to move more at nights and where I come
from if you see a Pangolin we have
always said you ghosts and 90% chances
of winning a lottery that is if you see
a Pangolin at night but if you see a
fumbling during the day you have the
chances of one hundred one percent of
winning a lottery so not sure how many
are the people believe that but from the
villager come from that is the belief
during the night
90% of what you'd want to do chances are
it will happen and to go well if you
then truce on you need to come close to
me and we make a plan and the only one
condition Tristan will give you the
loader you in the you know how to kill
me twenty percent relax and maybe give
Archie ten percent so if that's the deal
Tristan come talk to me tonight and I'll
show you how to go about it
all righty keep hunting and put it see
who could be on the road story calm down
Kenny imma see how luck you might be
I'd be very happy to see a Pangolin
nursery the Pangolin was brought out of
the barrel because Audrina
yes that sounds great deal I don't know
whether Sydney want to join in my deal
Tristan of getting 20% revelatory a
Sydney what do you think of that
I am still looking for one of these cat
via in the area and at the same time I
am very jealous about a Tristan with a
beautiful Pangolin something I haven't
seen here in Juma years I have seen a
Pangolin before and a story about the
Pangolin I want to share with you is
that when a Pangolin is killed by an
animal or by anything if the blood of
the pollen touches the ground in Vanda
traditionally we believe that the rain
is not going to come it is going to be a
drought yay a Pangolin we believe that
when it's on the ground when it's dead
blood touching the ground is gonna bring
the drought so it's one of those animals
you are not allowed at all to kill
invader
so if you kill a family in there you're
going to face a lot of problems
but if the Pangolin is dead naturally
and this is what happens normally the
scale of the Pangolin is taken and you
can put it in the glass with water to
give the infant and other people to
drink before the winter season in order
to chase away the cold and to protect
them against the flu
and so now let's quickly go back to the
Pangolin in the Maasai Mara with Tristan
well yes we're still sitting with our
penguin and our riveting moth that is
bouncing around but penguin still hasn't
moved at all we've been sitting quietly
in the hope it would decide to unravel
itself and start moving but it's locked
in tight I think that thing is going to
stay as tightly bound as it can for
quite some time and like I said I was
betting you had 13 lines trying to bite
you you would also probably be in
similar situation now adding to what
Sydney was saying is about pangolins
I once spent some time we had a funeral
at one of the camps that I worked at
because one of the owners unfortunately
passed away and on the day of the
funeral we were talking and chatting
about things and we went out in the
afternoon Drive and we saw penguin in
facts that photograph I showed during
that broadcast just now with the kind of
penguin unravelled that night actually
is that same shot and the guys were
telling me a lot of the local guys and I
don't notice it you might be able to
confirm this but that they were saying
often when somebody passes away their
penguin gets seen and that it is a sign
of that person is still there and it's
almost like a message from them which is
very very interesting because today
funny enough a somebody that I know and
a friend of actually Sebastian that is a
guide was was unfortunately killed by an
elephant yesterday and so it makes you
wonder this is the fourth penguin that
I've seen the day after somewhere all
day although after that somebody has
passed away which is a very kind of
weird weird thing in many respects and I
don't really know it could just be
coincidence completely but this is what
the guys told me and what they believe
and it's I suppose one of those things
you know it's a it's a interesting kind
of take on things now I'm really hoping
that this penguin decides that it's
going to unravel if we guys
and and kind of show itself orphanage
you can actually see it and the main
reason why I wanted to actually move is
that you can then listen to it and
listening to a Pangolin sounds really
odd it's not that they call or make a
noise but when these guys walk um they
have the scraping sound as these kind of
plates shift and move you can hear the
scraping of them together and it's a
really cool sound it - obviously very
unique to them and it's not something
that a lot of people here so I'm hoping
that they will do that now Lady Bird you
say we being very kind in saying that
that's quite a kind of special thing and
it is it's a it's an interesting kind of
whole story and and like I say it's
obviously always sad when one of the
guiding fraternity unfortunately has an
incident with a wild animal and and you
know bad things happen but it's a weird
thing that penguins come out and and
like I said that the time before when it
was happened with that kind of funeral
and stuff for the guys was just saying
it's it's almost a sign of that person
coming and saying to everybody you know
it's okay well you know we store out in
a bar so that's what they say and I
don't know if anyone else has had that
experience and a lack of a certain you
might be able to be kind of somebody
that can verify if it's in his culture
because obviously Sydney's cultures
slightly different to where we are in
the sabi sands so Laura says giving you
chills well I know it's that's weird
thing I like I say it's a something
that's you know you you obviously don't
really kind of give it too much notice
when you kind of hear it but then when
they start adding up it starts to become
a weird coincidence in many respects all
to be something that could be who knows
depending on how you kind of see things
obviously like I said I mean I I sit on
the fence with these things but it's
just weird hearts happened at four of
the times that I've seen a panga and
somebody has kind of passed away within
a few days or day before seeing one so
very weird um but unfortunately I could
say it's still curled up I was really
hoping that it's going to kind of come
out and walk around for you and we get
to see it
but that initial kind of part where we
saw it with the line is just absolutely
ridiculous stall to see that line kind
of with its pores on a Pangolin is
something that is very very rare to see
and in fact probably the only place that
you see it with any sort of regularity
is in the in swallow in the Kalahari
Desert Steve Lyons often playing the
Penguins there it's a good place to
actually see penguins a little bit more
regularly than what we do now I must
apologize earlier I probably you is
completely out of control when we saw a
Pangolin and probably spoke at a million
miles an hour and it was very excited
but that's the way it is a trader
actually I shouldn't even apologize
about it because because penguins are
that special
I believe if series were so flurry and
hopefully you guys at home were also
kind of in much excitement and lots of
kind of I don't know nervous energy yes
but it's not nervous energy I don't want
the way it is it's an excitement is the
way that's all there is to it but it got
to be one of the most special things
that no way did I ever think that we
would see a Pangolin tonight mano you
must possibly quite luckiest anglers
because my no actually is the the last
Safari live crewmembers have seen a
penguin he's when did you see him a
month ago about a month ago money saw a
Pangolin far from where we are now so
different not the same penguin and so it
down towards you know where we saw kick
Kenya the other day
Lucy spotted it's in Lucy's whose heart
newest crew member has seen a penguin
before many of the older stuff so you
know maybe it's man who that's their
luck but this afternoon is just been one
of those kind of very special drives and
it's an interesting thing because when
we left for drive and we were coming
down the hill Monday and I actually
weren't supposed to be on Drive this
afternoon James has had to do a lot of
work with the trainees during the course
of the day and so we said we'll go out
and we'll handle things so you can you
know
bit of extra time and get some time with
the trainees before he goes I leave and
we were kind of hitting arts and I think
tomorrow I feel like we're gonna get a
you know an imp exciting and let's go
back to the wall alors and I'm pretty
sure that they might have been a few
people that's we're a bit skeptical of
going to lions in a hot afternoon and
and you know not much happening but from
the moment we got there you know the
Lions are wake up we had the storm that
came in that epic views of that and then
to you know to get to this point where
we're at right now with the Pangolin is
is pretty ridiculous and I'm sitting
here talking and I it's almost one of
those moments people to pinch yourself
that on the screen is a little scaly
ball called a Pangolin and that it's
just sitting there ever so still amazing
now Emily you are more than welcome to
stay with us I'm quite happy to talk for
five more minutes if everybody's happy
to listen to me talking for five minutes
hopefully our penguin will move you know
what's going to happen is we going to
finish the show in the Penguins came to
unravel about 50 seconds after the kind
of credits roll so we'll hope that it
doesn't have this penguins and it's not
penguin we're talking to you you have to
unravel so that everybody can see you so
that everyone spreads the word about how
special you are and that's people
stopped hunting your kind okay
penguins not listening stage but maybe
just not maybe it just takes a while to
sink in past all of those Gera carotene
skit now I'm a lot of your agreeing with
me look well I'm gonna stick around with
it for a little bit softer than even the
show and if it does decide to wake up
I'm not gonna stay forever it will stay
for a few minutes often decide and see
if it is going to unravel and if it does
whether or not we can kind of get a view
for you guys so that you can kind of see
it
secret huh yes the moths do you really
like the penguin they are best friends
probably because in some way those moths
there we go then we go to meeting look
look look guys look it's moving it's
unraveling got one
now back down again it's getting there
starting starting to wake up
come on so if it's moving like that then
everything is okay it's not like I said
it's what did or so many many of you
might have thought it was dead but let's
just give it a chance
it's definitely moved a little bit
that's the first sign of movement we've
had since we first spotted it now come
on
maybe it's all the Matsu and it's
listening to us hopefully now we will if
we see it starting to kind of move a bit
more and a bit more then eventually we
will just extend the show a little bit
so don't worry if there is sign of
movement or not going to cut you guys
off and leave you there so hopefully it
will unravel but definitely little sign
of movement there slowly but surely it
should open a bit now Brent's is don't
be shy is that our Brent or is this
another print it's very confusing these
two brains so I don't know how Brent
he's doing and she's shame now while
he's sitting with this bangle and
talking about Brent but I believe it's
another brain but shampoo Brent yeah
that spoke to Jamie yesterday evening
just to see how brain tea was doing
because obviously had an emotional day
mr. day morning and on top of that had
that very very bad infection in his
tooth and panky was really not doing
very well yesterday evening in terms of
his face was very swollen and sore and
but he had managed to get some
antibiotics and hopefully that will help
but Jamie said that Jamie was he was
struggling a little bit so I think he
was a bit hard so on to as much as he
probably wouldn't have said so he I
think you know there's a big decision
for him to decided to leave all this and
not something that he he took like yeah
you know obviously being probably one of
yes hopefully can't grow up into a boat
and recover but you know being one of
probably Prince I would say better
friends at safari live in fact the fact
that someone is
his groomsmen list is you know we
chatted a lot about his decision before
he made it and you know whether or not
it was the right call any is very
conflicted about it even until the last
day so you know I think you maybe feel a
little sorry for himself yesterday but
it's hopefully a speedy can recovery so
mentee if you are watching or if you
Jamie or anybody even hope that you're
feeling better today and that your face
starts to come right and that your your
tooth is settles down the antibiotics is
on or work pretty quickly so that should
be good come on little penguin you gave
us all hope come on so not opening us
Peter no we can't tell if it's a pizza
or Patricia um unfortunately yet if its
unravels and it starts to walk then
potentially and it's very tricky because
you've got to see it from the underside
and if it's got little soil and memories
then you might see that it's it's a
nutrition but it's very tricky to tell
the sex of a penguin that's an easy
thing to do a bit icky if they roll up
and curled in a ball like this now we
are coming towards the end of the show
but well let's just give it an extra
minute or two you're supposed to kind of
finish I think in the next sort of 40
seconds or so but we'll give it an extra
two or three minutes let's just give it
a bash you never know maybe it unravels
let me get to see something one of the
probably the nicer penguin sightings
I've had was on a evening very similar
to this a storm it kind of comes through
and it just passed and a penguin kind of
emerged and it's actually set and
watched us for a while and it was almost
as if it was kind of tasting the aim and
it kept sticking its tongue up directly
at us which was absolutely amazing and
could see his long tongue another kind
of stick it out and then look at us and
stick it out and it sat there for what
must've felt like a long time it must
have been only about five minutes
and it's just getting sticking its
tongue in and arts and to see the tunnel
is actually pretty incredible so
hopefully I'm really hoping then it's
going to do something for us there was
at least movement which means we know
that it's not dead which is good thing
because obviously those are things that
we kind of panic about from time to time
but it's at least you know it's okay
everybody is relieved I believe that we
do not have a date penguin on our hands
yes I think we all are so Paula you say
come on little fella time to wake up and
show everybody
I agree Paula come on it would be so
nice if it did wouldn't it you've been
given so much by nature today I suppose
we can't really be upset if it doesn't
but it would just be the cherry on top
if it just emerged with its low face and
gave us even a 50 second view of the
face and looked at us a little bit and
then started to move off I would be more
than happy and would be thoroughly
thrilled by it so come on be nice to us
shame I think it's beam-in little bit's
pizza my absolute pleasure thank you for
being along for the ride that you got to
see your first penguin and many many
others I'm sure they've got to see their
first one and it's an absolute pleasure
to have you guys like I said it's when I
was talking about it earlier today when
we're talking about computers and you
guys participating in this is what makes
the show so special and why it's it's
such a delight for us as as guides to
work for something like this I mean we
must remember that most of us this is
completely foreign and talking to a
camera and those kind of things we used
to talking to people in real life on the
back of vehicles and being able to
interact with people and and not just
you know the six people eight people
that are in the back of your car but the
you know hundreds and thousands that are
on the drives and the fact that that
community has such a diverse background
and so many people with so many
interesting little bits to add to it
just makes it that much more special and
we're a very small part of this entire
kind of community and you guys are
certainly the bulk of it and which like
I said it makes it an interesting and
special kind of thing to do and
certainly a very big pleasure to come
arch every day and show you guys
wildlife through our eyes which you know
is a very special thing for us because
we get to see the things we like and
hopefully that may rubs off on you guys
she wanna you say you've never heard of
a penguin until now and that's precisely
what I was hoping for is why I would
hope to get penguin sightings is because
they so little that so many people have
no idea what a penguin is and when they
see a penguin they always lump it with
an armadillo and it's not an armadillo
it's not in any way the same animal it
doesn't occur in the same places and it
certainly is in a far worse off state
than when armadillos are so when people
see it they may start to ask questions
about it they start to look into it they
start to realize these things and
hopefully that can turn the tide and we
can start to actually protect these
animals far better than what we have
already because we are failing this
animal rather
rather rather baddie and and it's not
great
the kid juice Oh so whoever told you
that it was a cross between a penguin
and a lion has has gotten wicked sense
of humor and as sold you down the river
I'm afraid so
it is not at all and while it may be a
mythical creature in many respects
because we hardly ever see it certainly
isn't something that is a cross between
anything
Oh little penguin all right sir Emma I
think it's we can finish up now and I'll
search if I promise our sins I'll sit
with it for another 10 minutes or so and
if it does I'll certainly go back live
again so just pay attention to your
notifications and then we can you know
because otherwise we might sit here for
3-4 hours but I will sit with it myself
and see if we can send all the other
guys home but anyway hopefully you've
enjoyed it hopefully the penguin does
move and we'll see you again just now if
it doesn't though what a special special
special evening we've had we've had a
bit of everything today from getting
stuck marshmallow Club to pangolins
to Lions to storms to all kinds of folk
lures with Sydney so from Sydney David
myself a man for final control all the
cam ups it's been an absolute pleasure
we'll see or tomorrow morning on the
Sunrise Safari